notes for good sound quality it is
important for members to speak clearly
with some volume soft voices may be
heard but hard to understand
the microphones in the world pick up
sound very well and we need to be close
with outside
conversations and uh the computer will
be operated remotely by staff to mute
if we take a break as to this morning
the sign-in sheet stopped accepting new
entries for people who wanted to speak
at eight a.m the day of the cleaning
hearing after signing after that time
the committee will not have their name
before them
however the chair will provide an
opportunity for you to speak after all
registered names are called
at that time we asked you again to be
organized the sign-in sheet actually
closes for purposes of registering your
opinion at 11
59 on the day of the hearing
the one public hearing we have this
morning we actually have the most
people signed up to speak that we have
had for any public hearing this year
in election law so tests we will be
putting a time limit on the majority of
testimony that is before the committee
as to today as chair of the house
election law committee i find that due
to the state of emergency deployed by
the governor as a result of the covenant
pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order 12
percent until executive order
20 2004 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically
this is the public hearing on bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
to the house calendar for today
and as noticed an executive session will
be occurring
on all bills remaining referred to the
committee
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that all members
of the committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting with the student
electronic gaming platform
and the public has the ability to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in the
meeting by the zoo and platform will
order by telephone
all necessary access information has
been available in the house calendar and
through
the electronic calendar on the general
court website and the research
reading does comply with how tools and
rsa number 1a
and anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271 3600 or email
hcs
and in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled please note that all votes
during this meeting
will be done by goal and before we start
the report for attendance i ask you to
join me
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation
under god indivisible with justice
for all thank you very much
representative bergeron uh i am
president i'm
participating remotely from my home in
nashua there is
no one in the room uh with me at the
present time thank you
representative barry president
here in nashua alone
representative freitas
representative freitas i know i've seen
you
yeah muted commuted
i'm not here okay i'm unmuted now thank
you i'm
at home in manchester alone good morning
madam chair
representative growing
representative handblitz i am present
in my home in portsmouth and my son is
in another room
thank you representative hamer i'm
present
in manchester in my home alone
representative hayward president
representative lane i'm
president in my home office in concord
and i'm alone in the office my husband
is in the house
representative mcdonald president
representative mooney here at the lob
representative morehead present in
hanover new hampshire alone
representative fruit home o'brien i'm
jerry cronkite
representative kweily
representative sandler
i am uh home in my home office uh
in somersworth my husband and our cats
are in the living room
that's all of us there are
representative sweeney
here representative i'm
president here congress the uh
representative ward here in portsmouth
one family member in the house
and the clerk is here okay all set
thank you madam clark we have one
hearing today
uh what apparent schedule we heard today
on uh john germain amendment to senate
bill 89 the prime sponsor of that is the
chairman of our committee
representative griffin of goffstown i'd
like to represent our recognized
representative
for the purposes of introducing this
amendment
thank you mr chair
and thank you to members of the house of
extra company
my name is margaret griffin and i am a
fourth term representative from boxtown
and i come
before you today to introduce amendment
1445 h to house bill
excuse me senate bill 89 this amendment
was prepared at my request in order to
address what i consider
to be a direct assault on the
sovereignty of new hampshire and its
ability to conduct its elections
this amendment provides that should our
federal government pass
before the people act of 2021 and we'll
have
no event on the conduct of new hampshire
elections for
state and county officers that
particular language was selected to
cover both constitutional
officers and those permitted under
statute
i know that some of you are wondering
why such an amendment would be offered
when the act
known as hr1 now s1 reportedly
only affects elections and voting for
federal offices of the congress it is
offered for
two reasons the first is to oppose this
large expansion of federal governments
while some say the federal government
has the right to govern the federal
elections
leaders specifically scholars dispute
the breadth of that authority
and irony the constitution to give
primary authority for elections to the
state
but allow congress to make her alter
such regulations
and it is that regulatory authority
which is being interpreted
as expansively as possible to override
what states currently provide the second
reason
is because history tells us that this
legislation
will not just affect federal laws both
the national national voter registration
act and the health american vote act
were to address federal office yes both
of those became
major state issues new hampshire
received an exemption from those
acts but the possibility of receiving an
exemption from
s-1 at this time given the
implementation
date proposed and the fact the bill
restricts jurisdiction
for disputes over the act to the
washington dc district court
only makes an exemption unlikely
owen and by the way washington dc will
become a state
i have with me a copy of the for the
people's act
of 2021 it is over 800 pages
addressing voting campaign financing and
ethics
while all important issues in the
election i speak today to
some of the provisions regarding voting
and how it will affect the
camp as fund eliminates voter id
requirements over 75 percent of
americans support voter i.t requirements
and the majority of our residents
support it and we have such a law
it will no longer be applicable if s1
passes so
what do we do s1 provides for the
registration of persons
at the age of 16 a proposal heard by
this committee in prior years
and rejected by the people's
representatives
s1 has automatic voter online
registration with opt-out provisions
a proposal heard by this committee and
the legislature in recent years and
rejected
this will be a major change providing
the providing of services at all levels
of our state and communities it will be
at great cost
and while there is money that is
allegedly associated with the act who
knows how much it could be
it will have to be applied for a branch
process will have to be gone through
when it's reported and accepted
it is contingent on unspecified terms
and conditions of the federal government
s-1 has voted that occurs over weeks
weeks it's in direct opposition to our
constitution which provides that
we have an election day and on that day
the votes
are to be counted and the results are to
be publicly declared by the moderator
at each polling place on the night after
the election
close with s1 our communities will have
to begin to
allow voting at least 15
days before election day and then
continue to receive
absentee ballots for 10 days after
election day
our elections are run in new hampshire
in our communities by
our clerk elected moderators and
supervisors with
volunteers how is this process going to
be managed in your community how will it
be stacked how will it be paid for
as one also provides that polling places
need to remain open for at least 10
hours a day during the early voting
period
and 12 hours on election day our minimum
hours in new hampshire
are eight hours we're showing to rsa 659
ford what about small communities that
can't
count paper ballots with polling places
that are open for less than an
hour rsa 659-3a
provides for the early closing of polls
in dicksville launch
and hearts location in millsville
will those communities have to provide
for weeks of voting
and be open for such extended hours
as one also provides for no excuse
absentee voting
our constitution doesn't have such a
provision and after
three attempts to change the
constitution you
still are supposed to have a disability
in order to vote absentee
the broad exemption of november 2020
does not apply
to a specific emergency order that is
not no longer applicable
and additionally it was still not no
excuse absentee voting
do we charge our election officials if
s1 passes
to run our elections in direct violation
of our constitution
s1 requires the mailing of an
application for an absentee voter for
all
voters that check those 60 days prior to
the election
it requires prepayment for mailings out
and
from potential voters and it requires
drop boxes to be available 45 days
before elections for ballot drop-off
our communities are going to pay for
those items
most communities have started to work on
their budget for next year
how is that going to be paid for and the
ballot dropbox procedure is one that has
been considered
and rejected by the new hampshire
legislature
not only have these processes
and procedures been considered and
rejected by this committee over the
years some of them were considered
by the new hampshire superior court just
last year
many of the provisions such as unmanned
drop boxes no excuse absentee voting
prepaid mailings extended hours extended
days
were brought forward in 2020 with
litigation brought by the american
federation of teachers
as the primary plaintiff who asked that
the court
ordered the state to implement those
provisions in 2020.
that request was rejected in the
superior court
the court recognized that our processes
and procedures were
appropriate in light of our constitution
and state laws
new hampshire has a process for election
that has worked for our communities
do some people say changes can be made
yes
does that require upending the entire
process that has been adopted and
prescribed by our constitution no in
april 2020 the unh survey center
released polling data
that provided that 90 percent of our
voters said it was
easy or some likely to vote and they
were overwhelmingly profited
in the processing of the election
ballots and results
new hampshire has placed in the top
three of all states and voter
participation rates for the last
four presidentials some say this
amendment will cause us to have two
elections and i disagree
this amendment is only making clear what
proponents so that's what
say is the case it affects voting for
federal offices only
it is s one that is forcing the states
if they need to to have two electric
processes
not this amendment as to how to
implement
voting next year should estimate pass
being up to our chief election officer
and the legislature at that time and
step out of government as it always
has but pending that it should not be
directed to our state
i present to you that s1 will have a
dramatic
and unconstitutional impact on our
elections
and i strongly disagree with our sitting
senator
who has said that it really doesn't
change the way new hampshire would run
its elections
i choose to give us an opportunity to
charter force that will allow us to
conduct
our elections in a manner that has
produced the high voter
participation rates confidence in the
conduct and a process that voters
find it easy to navigate and if you're
concerned about the impact of
s1 with this amendment i suggest you
call the federal delegation
while two members of our technical
delegation have already voted for it
two still have the opportunity to stand
in washington supported by financial
voters
and our negative constitution they
should be voting
no on s1 but i ask that you vote yes
on 1445.
that's what the amendment as proposed
proposes to do
i want to thank the committee for their
time and listening to my testimony
i given the amount of people who have
signed up to speak
on this bill as i expected with
other people a question
maybe one or two questions if community
members have any but i think the time
will be best stuff for the public
okay any questions for representatives
thank you very much i'm sorry uh
i you brought up our senators
and uh they approved of this
and i've noticed a difference
um in people that have been involved in
new hampshire politics that have also
been
on this committee and have looked at the
legislation's closest are you aware of
i know that our senators were you know
were former governors and prior to that
former
state representative are you aware of
them ever serving on this committee
anyone in our delegation that's
approving of this one right now
i'm not aware thank you
i'm going to retake committee members
i'm going to remain seated on the side
so that representative mcdonald
can collaborate as chair with the
remaining balance of the committee
thank you public hearing thank you thank
you representative
as representative griffin indicated when
we opened this meeting
we do have the largest number of people
signed up to testify of any bills
considered so far this session
accordingly we are going to impose a
three-minute time limit
on anybody testifying we're going to
straighten
of course this three-minute time limit
representative maureen mooney is kind
enough to be reminding me when
we uh download the last 30 seconds i
will so notify the person
we'll go to the first person to testify
and that is senator james gray
i don't see senator gray
in the um the list mr
chairman if he would raise his hand if
he's there but i
didn't
listen all right great family is not
with us
no then i would like to move on to our
representative emmanuel especially
all right i'm moving him over thank you
very much
you're welcome thank you mr chair and
thank you
um to the committee for having me today
um you know i'm here to to testify
against uh this non-germain amendment uh
for sb 89 and you know for me
basically before the people act is a
critical reform package
to get dark money out of politics
something that has bipartisan support
you know stop billionaires from buying
elections crack down on corruption
and partisan gerrymandering protect free
the freedom to vote
and ensure elections are safe and
accurate and accessible
and the for the people act is essential
to restoring the public's faith in our
democratic institutions and ensuring
everyone's voice and vote is heard
counted and protected and so today's
hearing i think
i'm i'm just going to say is a i think
is a political extent nothing more
um it is an attempt to spread
misinformation and undermine our
democracy
and as a young leader in our state um i
hear it constantly how our
broken our government is i mean i've
heard elected elected leaders say that
we can't even trust our own government
um and it's just ignoring the clear
unworkable nature of this proposal and
by that i mean i have
you know creating two separate systems
it is disturbing to me
that some of my colleagues would go to
such great lengths to just
target one piece uh one piece of
legislation so
we should be working on implementing
things like electro electronic poll
books
online voter registration not wasting
our time on this silly amendment
i think um you know for us this sb 89 is
actually a bipartisan bill
and it's a pro voter bill that would
actually
improve our absentee ballot um pre-k
uh pre-processing process and curing so
i think you know a lot as it is is a
good bill but
adding this amendment would be would be
detrimental to
this bill and then i would also add that
i
i respect the chair uh of the committee
but i would also say that we um
new hampshire has not was not in the top
three in last year's uh
election turnout um you know states like
i think it was maine colorado um
i think it was minnesota that was the or
was yeah minnesota were the highest
last year so although we like to tell
ourselves that we are and we are an
active participant we're in the top 10
every four years um but like these
states are taking measures
to actually improve access to the ballot
box and we should be doing the same
so um and i'll i'll end with saying that
this bill would not
immediately happen overnight this isn't
like a okay where
automatically everything changes there
are provisions in the
uh in shr1 and s1 that would make it so
you know there would be timelines that
you wouldn't have that we would be
putting in
i'll but all in my my testimony there
thank you representative any questions
for representative
speech here yes representative
i'm sorry i'm sorry
thank you representative taking my
question
please help me understand because i
don't quite see it
how this how hr1
and s1 by relaxing motor id requirements
and other
requirements that help to ensure voter
integrity tell me how that
gets rid of doc money and politics i'm
confused on that maybe you can enlighten
how that does that
i mean this isn't a one thank you for
the question this isn't
one just one piece i mean voting
voting is i mean you know elections are
not just comprised of one specific act
this is this is a hundred percent this
is you know there are many parts to it
um so i in my in my view
you know making sure that we have you
know fair
that we have transparent elections and
seeing how much you know seeing where
where how candidates are funded is
incredibly important important to our
electorate
um now i don't think you know
i think voter right uh will you know
making sure that people have access to
the right to vote is a whole other part
of this
but you know transparency in how our
electeds get funded
is they'll come is another important
part of our election system
um but like i said it's not just you
know elections aren't just one thing
um they they're comprised of many
different variables that go into
elections as you know as you probably
had to raise money but you also
had to turn people out when we when we
all got elected so
um and you probably told folks to just
remember to show up
with the necessary requirements for for
voting but
you know it's nothing in this as we all
like to do new hampshire we don't like
to be siloed off there are many
but there are many different aspects to
this so
i'm sorry to interrupt uh mr chairman
but i i've i've gotten some
reports from from members that are
accessing the meeting by
zoom that it's difficult to hear the the
people in the committee room
if you can just be mindful of where the
microphones are
and make sure you're you're talking
you're near one when you're speaking
it would be helpful
you know i think it's a little soft i
mean i can
call for tech support to come turn
things up if you're near a mic
it doesn't really sound um like you are
okay thank you for letting me know you
gotta follow up
thank you thank you uh mr chair and
thank you representatives taking the
following questions
uh representative are you aware of any
um
voter in your hampshire in the last
election that uh wanted to vote that
wasn't
given the chance to vote either by
absentee ballot or invoke balloting are
you aware of any specific instance of
that happening in new hampshire
so yeah um it's funny you mentioned that
i've heard of people being turned
away for being registered being able to
register to vote
because of misinformation that um that
the person that the the person with the
registrant
um was being was given they were like
for example there were
newly naturalized citizens who were
being told oh
like you need to have your exact date of
of when your
when your naturalization was and you
know person you know it's an important
day in their lives but not everybody
remembers that day and because they
didn't have it
they were told oh you can't register um
and because of that they were denied
their right to vote
you can't be given an absentee ballot or
sorry an affidavit if you're not a
registered voter
and if you can't get registered so there
were situations like that
i know that we have you know we're all
trying our best because you know a lot
of us are
we're conducting this this is this
democracy as
as best we can but um you know i i
wouldn't say that there is you know i
appreciate the affidavit process but
it's not as clear and cut as we all like
to think it is
any other questions representative
okay thank you very much for your
testimony
my next sign up to testify is
representative amanda tall
representative
and if she could just raise her hand it
would be helpful
thank you
[Music]
mcdonald it's still a little difficult
to hear you
honorable can you hear me yes
honorable members of the house election
law committee my name is amanda
elizabeth tolle and i represent cheshire
which encompasses the city of keene at
large i'm here to testify against the
anti-for the people
amendment to sb 89
it is nothing but a voter suppression
tactic guys
as a concern about the very popular for
the people act
the support for the provisions in the
for the people act are widespread
because people want to restore
faith in democratic institutions and
assure that everyone's voice is heard
the amendment before you today by
creating separate
elections and procedures for state and
county elections will do the opposite
it will make it harder and more
confusing for people to vote
and disenfranchise folks across the
board but especially those who are
already more vulnerable to
disenfranchisement
including our state's young people as a
representative for keen
many of my constituents are college
students at keene state college and
antioch university
these are young folks who may be voting
for just the first or second time
and will be more likely to be confused
and hampered by two separate sets of
elections and registration procedures
we want young people to be greeted
warmly into the democratic system
so they will be lifelong voters and
contributors to our civic life
not turned away by red tape to become
cynical disbelievers
in our system of elections finally as a
state rep who is also going through the
budget process right now
it is important to note that the
provisions in this amendment will likely
cost money to implement
as we know the budget is already
incredibly lean and does not fund the
critical social services
needed by granite staters to instead
spend money on anti-democratic voter
suppression procedures is an affront to
granite staters
and not in the best entrance of my
constituents or any of the citizens of
new hampshire
thank you for hearing my testimony i
will not be taking questions today
thank you representative
next sign up to testify is
representative excuse
mr paul pay mr pay are you with us
i'm sorry who were you calling on paul
oliver
if he could raise his hand we do have
dave scanlon and tim horrigan
and representative horrigan with his
with their hands up
they apparently mr phase i do not
see mr fay
okay um secretary of state uh deputy
stanley would you like to testify
i've just promoted him thank you
thank you thank you mr chairman i just i
was able to get on
uh mr chairman before i start uh i would
like to say that secretary gardner
uh uh was interested in testifying
before the committee today
unfortunately he had a long-standing
commitment uh
with an essay contest um
uh winners that were involved with the
you know essays involving the
presidential primary
today was the awards ceremony before the
governor council and he is
currently attending that uh uh
madam chair may be interested to know
that that the winner was a 14 year old
from goffstown
and that person is getting their award
uh as we speak
um with that he has asked me to testify
uh on behalf of
the office and uh
and we are appearing in support of
the amendment sponsored by uh
representative griffin
h.r 1 or sr s1
from our standpoint is a federal
takeover of
the state's election process and
after reading through the bill uh in its
entirety
it is quite clear that if s1 were to
pass
it would change every every uh
area of our election process and really
it would not be recognizable
uh in the future compared to what we
have today and
i think representative griffin did a
great job
uh explaining some of the things that
were in the bill but the bill is far
more comprehensive than that
um just a general statement before we
start you know the election process
has to work for all voters and
if there is a delicate balance that we
have to find
between uh making sure that it's easy to
vote
and also making sure that that the vote
is secure
that we that we reduce the risk as much
as possible
for fraud to take place the other side
of that is yeah we don't want to
enact policies that that
result in voter suppression
if we go too far in either direction
then we have a vast group of voters
who lose confidence in the election
because number one they either believe
voter suppression is taking place
or the other side of that is that
the fraud is rampant because it's too
easy for people to get on the checklist
and uh and exercise their right to vote
so
from an administrative standpoint we we
approach this with trying to find that
balance
where the the laws that we enact
are adequate enough so that the most
people
as reasonably possible have confidence
that their vote is going to
be counted and and and that it is not
unduly burdensome for them to cast that
vote
um just uh
jumping over to hr1 quickly that the
title of the act
and i'm referring to hr one because uh
our office did a briefing with the local
election officials
we put together a powerpoint um and
madame chair i believe that
you have a copy of that that you may be
able to make available to members of the
committee
uh if the committee members do not
already have that but i would point out
that the title
of the act is to expand americans access
to the ballot box
reduce the influence of big money in
politics
strengthen ethics rules for public
servants
other corruption measures for the
purpose of fortifying our democracy
and for other purposes that sounds great
and and i think that's
that is a general statement that we
should all strive for
the act itself as was mentioned
earlier is is very broad and addresses a
number of very large
topics it's broken down into divisions
division a
is related to voting division b
is related to campaign finance and
division c
is related to ethics
again a different subject matter our
comments are related to division a which
is the voting portion of this
um
the um and and when we talk about
division a there there are things in
that
in that bill that are good i mean we're
not going to
we're not going to deny that there are
some things in that legislation that new
hampshire already does
like same-day voter registration uh
there are provisions in there that deal
with electronic poll books
online voter registration portals and
increased
accessible voting opportunities for
individuals with disabilities
and those are all areas that our office
is currently working on
with the input of the legislature there
are bills pieces of legislation moving
through
our state legislature that deal with
those topics
that we are supportive of and we expect
that in the near future
we're going to be implementing some of
those provisions
um but as we get into further into the
uh the bill uh there are
statements of findings made by congress
and on page 20 of hr1
congress has made the finding that
states and localities
eroded access to the right to vote
through restrictions on the right to
vote
including excessively onerous voter
identification requirements
burdensome voter registration procedures
voter purges
limited and unequal access to voting by
mail
polling place closures unequal
distribution of election resources
and other impediments and i would
challenge any member of this committee
or the legislature
to to point to one of those areas that
is problematic
in the state of new hampshire
much of the material i would go over is
is in that
powerpoint the the pages from that are
taken directly from the text
of the bill uh when you put everything
together that is contained in that
we have major concerns about creating
opportunities for ballot harvesting
which has been problematic in some other
states in the past
and the provisions in there we believe
also make it
uh more difficult to maintain an
accurate
checklist of voters that are eligible to
vote making it
too easy to get unqualified voters on
the checklist
and this this bill makes it more
difficult to remove voters
that are unqualified uh if it's
determined that
that there's a problem there so with
that mr chair i will
uh stop and be happy to answer any
questions
thank you very much
uh thank you mr chairman uh mr deputy
um do you agree that the passage of this
amendment would require
um separating uh the federal and state
elections
for ballot purposes uh that would be one
option um and for the question
what would the other options be uh that
we have different ballots and different
checklists on the day of the election
uh can i have a further question mr
chairman for one more
thank you uh one more uh well in that
case
that being the case do you have any idea
what the financial impact of the passage
of this amendment would be for your
office
uh no not at the moment in fact we don't
know what the financial impact of the
passage of
s1 is going to be either and and and
that will be that would have been that
would have been my next question thank
you
okay um also the hand up representative
thank you thank you mr chair um mr
deputy
um i i understand you know that much of
your testimony focused on
legislation in the united states
legislature
um and i wonder if is your understanding
that this amendment
converts the new hampshire senate bill
89 into a referendum
on uh on the the senate bill one in the
national legislature
i think this amendment uh
fires a shot across the bow to congress
about the wisdom of passing such such
a such legislation that would be a
federal takeover of our election
let me just elaborate on that a little
more because if
this if s1 passes congress now controls
the election laws for the state of new
hampshire
all of these items that we've been
debating for over the years
at a local level determining whether it
makes sense or not
for our voters are now going to be would
now be determined by congress
and when you look at the makeup of
congress there's over 400 members
in the house of representatives new
hampshire has two of them
so who's really going to be writing the
election laws if this federal takeover
takes place it's going to be states like
california new york texas
all of those states that have large
numbers of
of members of congress new hampshire is
going to struggle
in that environment and and i don't
think that's healthy or fair
to the citizens of our state follow-up
please mr chair
all right so my understanding from that
answer is that yes this this amendment
converts this
bill into a referendum i.e a shot across
the bow
with respect to uh national legislation
is there concern in the secretary of
state's office in the state of new
hampshire that
the office's stand on national
legislation
will compromise the nonpartisan standing
and integrity
of the new hampshire secretary of
state's office
the the the the climate you know in
in politics now is that that there are
polar
there's a great deal of polarization and
it is difficult
uh for an office like secretary of state
no matter what
we're talking about to administer the
elections
and take positions on bad pieces of
legislation when
we see it and not be accused of being
partisan one way or the other
but but if we don't speak up we're not
doing our job we're not
we're not uh you know alerting uh
our citizens to uh what is going on
and as i mentioned at the very beginning
and i i've repeated this you know that
position
for years uh when i've given testimony
is that
there is a delicate balance that we have
to find
between making voting easy and making
sure that it's secure enough that
people have confidence that their votes
are are being counted and not being
deluded or
other fraudulent activity taking place
and
that is the perspective that we are
approaching this issue from it is not a
partisan
uh uh position it is uh one of
administration
thank you representative o'brien thank
you mr chairman
uh thank you deputy stanley for joining
us
my question is about
the um the reaction
of this legislation from
local town clerks and supervisors of the
checklist
and town moderators who run our
elections in new hampshire and when i
think of any bill i think of them first
and i think of how
feasible and reasonable anything is to
implement here on the ground
in real life in new hampshire and
i recently read an article where they uh
they questioned 24 town clerks and 21 of
them
opposed the for the people act
and they would have approved of this
amendment then and i would i would like
to know what you think
when you had a recent uh meeting with
local town clerks throughout the state
and those clerks are you talking about
the polarization
and partisanship of this those clerks
and those officials they
they come from all political spectrums
they're all they're on the left they're
on the right the republicans the
democrats they're independents they're
everywhere
how is the reaction from those people on
the ground running elections in new
hampshire on this uh
bill on the for the people act and on
this event
uh thank you for that question uh we
work very closely with
uh local election officials generally
uh but very closely with the clerks
um we discussed legislation
uh that is taking place with them and we
did give a briefing
on hr1 a couple of weeks ago
just to inform them of the contents of
that bill
so that they had an understanding of
what was being proposed
we did not uh after that event take
place paul the clerks
uh in any way um you know i would think
that they
share the same concerns that we have
because you know we are in the
in the business of administrating
elections uh together
but but i have not taken a poll i have
not heard from
uh uh you know the the executive
committee of the clerks
on whether they've taken a position or
not but
you know as as legislators you may want
to reach out
to your local election officials and ask
them uh
you know if if they attended that
briefing and and uh you know what their
opinion is of this federal legislation
thank you our representative lane
thank you mr chair um debbie scanlon
first the powerpoint that you referred
to um
i have not seen it nor was i aware of it
so if it could be shared with all
members of the committee
i would appreciate it um
you also asked in your testimony when
you read out the things on page 20 of
the bill
if anyone would just say that that
voting any of those problems existed in
new hampshire
even the legislation on sb3 where it
requires
multiple phd degrees to understand the
affidavit
i would say we have at least one of
those problems that you read out
would you agree with that i
i think i would disagree with you on
that point
um and to answer the first part of your
question i'll be happy to make sure that
the committee gets a copy of the
powerpoint okay
and uh follow up one more question
please mr chair
thank you um if i heard you correctly
deputy scalin i think you referenced
in your testimony you talked about
keeping our vote pure
language is important and perhaps
because i grew up in the deep south
that smacks of jim crow i'm sorry i
represented i don't mean to interrupt
you but
your screen froze up on me for like four
seconds
you if i heard you correctly you
used the term keeping our vote pure
and and i i just wanted to say that
as someone who grew up in the deep south
snacks of jim crow
talk and i think we need to be careful
as you indicated
this is a highly charged issue and i
just wanted to make you aware
that that may touch off that type of
language
it certainly had a knee-jerk reaction
for me
i don't know if that's true for everyone
on the committee but
um i think we need to remember
i yeah i i don't recall using words
keeping a vote pure
if i did it was
i just don't recall saying that exactly
that way okay
all right well maybe i misheard so thank
you
thank you representative
thank you mr vice chair uh deputy
scanlon
in looking at the proposed amendment
could you tell me what provisions in
this amendment
would give you or any other election
official the authority
to conduct parallel elections for
federal offices
and that for state and county offices
including
adapting changing or making
any other types of edits to voter
registration setting up the polling
place checklist procedures
counting the ballots and so on
uh i can't point to anything in the
amendment however if sr
if s1 were to pass we would be doing a
major rewrite
of all of our election laws further
question mr vice chair
so then if senate bill one does pass
and that both agrees is pure speculation
uh major legislation is going to have to
be introduced anyway to
uh to make sure that new hampshire's
laws conform with
or in or can work with the federal law
is that correct
yes okay no further questions thank you
thank you representative barry thank you
deputy assistant
can you hear me all right i'm a little
far away from the microphone uh if you
could just speak up
you're slightly muted i've never been
accused of that not talking about that
of course i'll take that as a compliment
um has any member of our federal
delegation spoken
with you or your office directly about
s1 or hr1
nothing i'm aware of why do you think
that is this is
as you say a major takeover of our
elections why do you think our federal
delegation all four members congressman
tapas senator hassan senator shaheen
and carmen from lincoln custer could not
be bothered to reach out to
the office that runs our elections in
new hampshire
uh i don't know the answer to that
question representative
i i think i do i think it's because they
don't care
any other questions for deputy stan
let's see not uh representative
thank you uh mr chair and thank you
deputy stanley for taking my question
um do you see this
how do you see this in in light of the
federal constitution and the state
constitution how do you see
s1 as relating to the constitutional
requirements for
elections well
s1 is in conflict with provisions
of new hampshire's constitution um
you know and yeah i'll just leave it at
that
okay any other questions for deputy
stanley
if we're done deputy stanley thank you
very much
thank you also uh we have representative
timothy horrigan
uh signed up uh here i would like to
testify
representative oregon go ahead you have
three minutes
he's on his way okay thank you
here i'm all set thank you and brimpton
timothy horrigan i represent
traffic county district six which is the
towns of durham and mad
very durham it's not uh it's probably
worth mentioning durham is a uh
bermuda college town and um so one of
the many
aspects of voting laws and sorts of
controversies the whole issue of
residency because we have a large number
of residents who are students some
and uh actually one of the things with
the student voting and won't go to it
much of that is that we always assume
that if you lived out of state before
you came
to new hampshire to attend college that
you could go to absentee or old state
and that's not necessarily the case
depending on what the uh law in the
other state is and certainly it's good
to have a certain amount of uh
uniformity in election law just for that
reason and many others um
this bill is first of all this has like
11 lines
of text and i really
i think we've we would have a hard press
we'd have a hard time
figuring out what exactly it means you
know
representing benjamin griffin did give
an explanation of what
she your intent was but i'm not sure if
that's what that 11 lines of text
actually
says um certainly it's massively
premature understand so far as
s1 and hr1 have not passed yet yet we
don't know what form
exactly what form they're going to take
um
the uh and so you know so like we
probably certainly um
governor scanlon is i probably disagree
with his opinion about
this particular amendment but he studied
in great detail certainly you should uh
consult with him you could probably have
a subcommittee where he could speak for
more than three minutes plus the
question time and uh
certainly this summer and this fall
whenever the bill passed we'll
have to examine it and see what changes
we need to make to our existing laws
but i um i think this is way too soon to
pass something like that and certainly
having
uh two different elections system for
federal state
offices that's uh that's a so my opinion
it sounds like a totally absurd idea
um especially given that we rely a lot
of federal funding for our state
elections
and just in the past uh
the past you know the past the federal
government has
felt and rightly so that local elections
are not entirely
beyond its purview so you know we uh
you know we we spend a lot of uh federal
money in fact we're putting the budget
together we spend as much federal money
as possible um we make lots of decisions
that affect federal
uh federal things but also
i also like i also just like to defend
the congressional delegation all of whom
are
friends of mine are saying they don't
care i don't know whether or not they've
called
secretary gardner deputy secretary
scanlon i'm sure
i'm sure if they picked up the phone and
called uh any of the senators or the
congress person's office they would
probably be happy
having to talk to them and i'm sure they
probably sounds like they have talked to
them so that's uh
that's just sort of an unfair
characterization certainly one of the
things we do
here at the state level is redistricting
in that effect thank you representative
your time is up any questions
representative oregon
thank you representative oregon for your
testimony oh thank you so anyway don't
pass the same adventures
the bill's great but this amendment just
doesn't add anything to it
thanks thank you very much also signed
up to speak is marjorie phillips
i do not see marjorie if she would raise
her hand
that would be helpful but she does not
appear
to be on the list i don't see her either
okay
thank you i also signed up to speak
and and i apologize i'll probably
mispronounce this name
kelsey rights
and here she is okay great thank you
my name is kelsey clementowicz i live in
portsmouth and i'm a civil rights lawyer
focusing on voting issues
i'm testifying today as a member of the
public but informed by my experience
working with local elections officials
and hearing from thousands of new
hampshire voters
hb 89 is a thoughtful and necessary bill
to assist
our hard-working new hampshire elections
officials and voters
but this amendment would do the opposite
the supremacy clause of the u.s
constitution establishes that the
federal constitution and federal law
generally take precedence over state
laws and even state constitutions
and so because new hampshire law cannot
preempt federal law
for federal offices elections
this amendment will only create two
separate schemes
and separate procedures for federal
offices and local
offices even on one election day so this
would more than double the work
of local elections officials during
federal election cycles
you can imagine federal officials must
offer voters one set of ballots
forms and rules for federal offices and
a separate set for local offices
they must also somehow manage and
maintain two different voter
registration apps and t-ballot lists
all for one election you can imagine how
confusing this would be for voters how
it would slow down lines on election
days and inundate clerks offices
so let's assume assume for a moment that
hr one passes
and includes online voter registration
and the sos
implements a comprehensive voter portal
system like they have in other states
where a voter can register change their
address
or request an absentee ballot online but
say a voter registers online and request
their absentee ballot
then they can only get a ballot for
federal offices under this amendment
so then they're calling their clerk
realizing they have to do additional
forms trying to get a ballot
but then that voter also needs to go on
election day to vote for local offices
then are they just given a ballot for
local offices
which would necessitate probably a
separate machine
in order to process that or are
moderators required to cancel their
absentee ballots which means they can't
be
fed into the machines until after the
close of polls
so these practical reasons are some of
the reasons why
attempts to create a two-tier election
system have failed or been struck down
across the united states
no state currently has this kind of a
two-tiered system
but the texas legislature actually just
heard a similar bill just last week that
was hb
4507 which would force voters to set to
register separately for federal and
state elections
also in response to hr1 but this bill
failed
even in the republican-controlled house
because of those costs and
administrative challenges also
kansas and arizona had bifurcated
schemes
both of which well the first of which
was struck down by the courts
and arizona did a settlement to unify
their system
in lieu of the court judgment so this
amended bill if passed
would probably be unlikely to survive a
legal challenge and would tie the state
up in costly and unnecessary litigation
finally this bill attempts to address a
problem that just doesn't exist
the details of hr1
any questions are you taking questions
man
yes please okay any questions for this
witness
okay i have no questions for you uh
actually uh representative lane
um thank you mr chair um
would you mind submitting have you
submitted your uh testimony in writing
no but i'm happy to would you please do
so thank you
thank you thank you mr chairman i would
remind the witness that since
we're we're going to be voting on this
bill today the same day as the hearing
and slightly more than 24 hours since
the amendment was sent out that she
better hurry
if her testimony isn't already reduced
to writing thank you
thank you representative cody
again thank you mr chairman this
amendment's been out for over a week
that's interesting i haven't seen it
available on the general court's website
representative cody
okay representative
okay all right thank you very much and
then yes please submit that
okay also sign up to testify is a phil
hatcher
i'm bringing him over thank you
thank you representative mcdonald and
the other members of the election law
committee
can you hear me okay i think we can
okay my name is phil hatcher i'm a
resident of dover i'm testifying to put
the debate that hr1 has provoked
into a historical context in 1903 new
hampshire amended its constitution to
require that voters be able to
quote read the english language and to
write unquote
in 1905 a law was passed to put in place
a literacy test to be applied when a
person went to register to vote clips of
paper were placed in a box
with each slip containing five lines of
the state constitution
a person applying to vote would reach
into the box to select a slip
and then needed to read all five lines
copy by hand one of the lines and then
sign their name
i'm not sure what the motivation was for
the literacy test
perhaps there was a concern about the
growth of the number of non-english
speaking immigrants at the time
but it seems clear that the law was
intended to suppress the votes that were
perceived as low quality
the lyricist the literacy test stayed on
the books
believe it or not until 1976 what was
the motivation to finally remove it
well it was the landmark 1965 voting
rights act
which aimed to eliminate the voting
apartheid that existed in many southern
states at the time
southerners and many state rights
advocates were upset about what they saw
as federal overreach
however both senators from new hampshire
voted for the bill
one republican and one democrat
new hampshire got caught in the war for
full citizenship of americans
for african americans because of the
literacy test
combination of having the literacy test
still on the books and 10 towns had poor
voter participation in the 1968 election
caused those 10 towns to be put to be
labeled as covered
jurisdictions requiring any changes to
their
voting procedures to be pre-cleared by
the
federal
this cost so i do not know why new
hampshire decided to leave its literacy
tests on the books
even after the passing of the 1965
civil rights act i hope that we would
all agree today that finally removing
the literacy test was a good thing
and that the civil rights act was a very
good thing for our nation
more recently in 1993 the federal
government passed the national voter
registration act
better known as the motor voter bill
this bill
is what encouraged us to go to election
day registration
as chair griffin mentioned in recent
years we've had high
voter participation
as measured by the secretary of state
and i believe that's in fact because of
this federal legislation that encourages
us to improve our voting
procedures so while it details hr1
surely should be debated
a blanket refusal to allow the federal
government to call for improvements to
our state voting practices has no
historical basis
thank you for listening to this
testimony and please vote against this
non-german
amendment thank you mr any questions for
mr hatcher
thank you very much sir for uh joining
us this morning
my next sign up to testify is like chris
hager mr reger are you with us
i'm sorry who did you i um call for
chris baker
i don't see him
i do not see him thank you
uh also signed up to speak is tim barnes
mr barnes are you with us
he i have promoted him because he was
next on my list
yes yes i am uh my name is ken barnes i
live in the country
hi can you hear me i can yes okay
thank you for hearing my testimony uh mr
chair members of the committee
my name is ken barnes i live in catooka
new hampshire
and i speak against this
amendment as non-germane it is what is
known to all of you no doubt and
politicians as a poison pill it is
something that is not actually related
to
the um bill that it's attached to
and it has the completely opposite in
effect as the bill itself sb 89
would help to make voting easier more
uniform
more fair in new hampshire and this
amendment
would do the opposite it would make
voting more difficult and
and more costly the bill
would by creating two separate
uh voting systems as deputy scanlan said
the solution to different might not have
to be different days it could be
on different ballots and with different
checklists and with different
procedures so everything would be done
double by
the local election officials voters
would have to follow two different
processes for for
get registering and and voting depending
on whether the state of new hampshire's
rules for their ballots were different
from the federal government's rules
for its spouse and that would cost money
and new hampshire doesn't have the money
but the most important thing is that it
would be
reduce the number of people who voted
secretary of state's office the governor
all of us have
appraised the new hampshire voting
system in the last election and previous
elections
as being open fair encouraging people to
vote
and making it easier for people to vote
during the pandemic
and i suggest similarly not during the
pandemic
it should be easier for more people to
vote and
that's what democracy is all about and
this would just create massive confusion
uh extra work for the local election
officials
and extra costs extra cost thank you i'm
almost done extra
costs to the local uh property taxpayers
who
god knows are already overburdened uh
with
uh uh paying costs so i
ask you to please vote no on the
amendment thank you very much for your
time
and i'll take questions if anybody has
them
any questions for mr barnes
thank you very much this morning
and thank you for having me my next sign
up to speak is cordell johnston
he is on the way thank you very much
you're welcome
uh thank you mr chairman cordell
johnston representing new hampshire
municipal association
thank you um and i'm i'm not exactly
sure what to say about this
amendment my initial reaction when i
read it was
uh that it it's crazy it can't work
um to have two basically two separate
processes for
elections um for reasons that
that other people have have talked about
but i have to admit that i had not paid
as much attention to hr1 as i
should i spend pretty much all my time
following state legislation and doesn't
leave a lot of time for
what's going on at the federal level um
i i had assumed and i think
correctly that the debate on hr1
was uh characterized by extreme
uh partisan hyperbole on both sides
and uh so so i decided that i should
actually get a little more familiar with
it and
i have read it um not not in any detail
but
have gone through it and and i realize
this isn't a hearing on hr1
but the there are in my opinion a lot of
good things in hr1
but there are also some things that are
would be impossible in new hampshire
um and the one thing i'll mention
specifically
is the early voting provisions uh
the idea that every and under this bill
every
voting uh location in new hampshire
would have to be open
10 hours a day for 15 days
before the election is simply insane uh
i'm i'm the moderator in my town
i do not have uh 10 hours a day
fit for 15 days in a row to spend
sitting at the polling place waiting for
one or two people
to come in and vote now something like
that may make sense in a place like
georgia or texas where you might have
half a million people
voting in one location but in
a town where you have you know 70 um
it it as i said it's insane
and and there's no there's no um
you don't have an option there's there's
no possibility for waiver
so i still don't think uh
i'm not at all convinced this amendment
is okay i'm not at all convinced this
amendment is the answer
i think we are in an impossible
situation
and my suggestion is that uh committee
members
try to work with our congressional
delegation to fix the problems in hr1
whether that's possible i uh
severely doubt but i think uh that's
that's what i would try to do ah thank
you very much
thank you mr johnson did anyone have
questions
yes representative barry mr johnson
you're here representing the
new hampshire musical association
correct
that's right as any member of our
federal delegation reached out to you
to discuss the implementation of s1 or
hr1 given that
your members would be the one
effectively implementing it
uh not to my knowledge i i think that we
probably will be contacting them
in the in the near future thank you to
express our concerns
thank you any other questions it's being
done thank you mr johnson
thank you all right next sign up to
speak
is lucas meyer mr meyer are you with us
he is and he's on the way
uh good morning uh mr chairman and
member of the committee my name is
lucas meyer i am the volunteer chair of
603 forward
i'm an organization that works with
working age adults in new hampshire
um and one of our core pillars is making
sure
uh our state has a healthy democracy um
as we move forward
um we obviously have great concerns
about this amendment
um one uh especially considering the
fact it's been attached to sb 89
which is the result of great bipartisan
work in the senate
so to attach this rather partisan
bill to it in order to
either sync it or change its purpose i
think is rather insidious
and then to the nature of trying to
establish two separate forms of election
in response
to hr1 which would transform and
strengthen our democracy
is concerning i would also like to
highlight
um following uh mr johnson's testimony
from the municipal association
uh there are write-ups happening to the
bill as we speak
including an exemption for communities
under 3 000 people
would not have that early vote provision
uh timelines have
been extended for implementation there
is clearly work
being done on this bill to make it work
for states like new hampshire
and it can work for new hampshire uh and
i
think this amendment i think this
hearing does a disservice
to voters of new hampshire a disservice
to our local election officials
um and i think given the rhetoric uh
put forth this morning i think the
intent is very clear
uh why this amendment was introduced and
i do
not think it is in the best interest of
our voters
of our elections and of our democracy uh
so i would
encourage this committee to really
consider if they want to pass this
especially not understanding what the
impact could be to our local election
officials
to our voters how much this would cost
it is clear there are not enough
answers to this amendment even remotely
close
uh to move forward with it um our
democracy
is an urgent need pair i think
everybody on this call i think everybody
in our state
would agree that government doesn't
always work
for the people um the only power grab
i see right now is in the abundance of
billionaires of corporate special
interest in our elections
and hr one s-one the for the people act
will fix that so i encourage this
committee i implore this committee
to vote this amendment down and pass sb
as is thank you okay
uh any questions from mr meyer i'm
seeing none
okay moving on my next sign up to
testify is michael thornton
i do not i i do not see mr thornton in
the
attendee list if if he is there um could
he raise his hand
and if he is the phone it would be star9
he's not there
okay next sign up to testify is alvin c
mr e with us
mr c is here
sir
you're still muted there it is
there you go uh um thank you
mr chairman and members of the committee
uh
i am in support of sp
89 and the amendment uh number four one
four four
five i don't like the idea of the us
congress
apparently violating the u.s
constitution and having a federal
takeover of
of the election process i would support
this amendment
even if it meant we have to have
separate federal and state ballots
with potentially some voters not
qualifying to
get both ballots and i would also
support this amendment if required new
hampshire to have two separate election
days
for the two different ballots i think it
would also be important
appropriate for the new hampshire
legislature
to create a resolution to send the
message to
senator hassan and shaheen to
urge them to protect new hampshire
elections
and to vote against u.s bills h.r 1 and
s-1
thank you thank you sir any questions mr
c
c none sir thank you for joining us
uh also signed up for speech this
morning is liz santorelli
ms center ellie are you of us she is and
on the way
thank you
my name is center you got three minutes
thank you my name is liz tentarelli i'm
president of the league of women voters
of new hampshire
and our mission is to empower voters
earlier this morning deputy scanlon said
election process
has to work for all voters
and i fear this amendment if
hr one passes and if this amendment
passes
will do exactly the opposite rather than
empower voters it will frustrate voters
it will discourage voters it will make
voters lose
confidence in a system we have great
voter turnout in new hampshire
as as we're all well aware and we have
confidence in our elections the governor
the secretary of state
and election officials have all reported
that
but if in the future
voters have to register one way for
federal elections
and register a different way for state
county and local elections they will
lose that confidence that the system
knows what it's doing that's not what we
want to have happen
we want voters to participate in our
democracy
now whether or not you like hr1
is up to each individual and i think
it's up to
the members of this committee to make
their views
known to our congressional delegation
but to try to legislate their viewpoint
uh seems like a reach of power just as
we are criticizing the federal
government possibly for a reach
and overreach here i think trying to
legislate
this way is also an overreach
i support sb 89
it's a good bill with bipartisan support
i oppose this amendment
because of the effects it will have on
the public the voting public
and it will discourage them from voting
when things get too complicated
people will not vote new hampshire has
good election laws we have for instance
a voter id law that has alternatives for
those who come
without a driver's license that's good
thank you we have some of those very
good things that are in hr1
i will leave the argument over hr1 up to
you
but to legislate it here is not the way
to go
thank you for the opportunity to testify
thank you any questions from this
senator ralph
seeing none moving on uh next sign up to
testify
is deborah nelson mr nelson are you with
us
i beg your pardon it went
thank you mike and i thank you for
allowing me this time
i live in hanover where i have
volunteered at the polls on election day
for the last 30 years
until i recently retired i taught
american history and literature for
three decades in new hampshire's public
schools
one important goal was to educate my
students about what it means that the
united states is a democracy and to
celebrate the points in history
when additional groups were enfranchised
i taught my students to take the act of
voting seriously
and encouraged them to volunteer so they
would understand the importance of
political engagement
in addition as a child growing up during
the cold war i lived in baghdad
as well as in east and west africa where
my father worked to support democratic
principles and to encourage governments
to follow the model of the united states
rather than that of the then soviet
union
it is therefore with no small degree of
dismay
that i respond to this amendment which
distorts
information contained in the federal
bill there's no other way of looking at
it
and it does everything possible to
create barriers to voting
when in a true democracy the right of
people to exercise their vote
should be of greatest importance the for
the people act
is not a quote federal takeover and i
really wish we could stop
using such charged language to discuss
bills that come before us this amendment
raises the potential for incredible
confusion on the part of voters as
you've heard
it expands the burden on town clerks
presents poll workers and supervisors of
the checklist with redundant tasks
and raises the cost for towns to hold
elections
and i would argue that the secretary of
state's presentation
two town clerks a few weeks ago
was distorted was riddled with
misinformation
and was highly not
independent in other words it was very
partisan
there are many questions that have
already been raised by other groups
about two checklists two voting days i
won't
repeat all of them but the for the
people act bill which is before
the federal government which this
amendment seeks to undermine
contrary to what you've heard from
several people provides
all necessary funding it is not
going to ask the state to do something
and not three seconds remaining
thank you it eases registration it gets
rid of the role dark money plays in our
politics
it has bipartisan support from the
american public
and it celebrates the democratic act of
voting this amendment
does none of that and i cannot imagine
nor have i heard yet this morning any
persuasive
argument for its passage i support the
bill
the voting bill before you but not this
amendment
which also has no fiscal note attached
to it
thank you
yes i see no questions for you man thank
you very much for joining us this
morning
thank you also signed up to speak
is elizabeth corral ms corello you with
us
she is it's hero yes okay
go ahead you have three minutes
good morning my name is elizabeth
carrell and
i live in concord uh i oppose this
amendment as um award supervisor of the
checklist
so my comments are specifically in the
realm of the local
impact and i really have two points to
share
you know as a supervisor we come to our
jobs as volunteers
and we're usually picking up the
procedure manual that the secretary of
state
prepares one two maybe three times a
year depending on the number of
elections occurring
this is not something we do every day so
we're reviewing that procedure manual
it's a tough job in that that procedure
manual is now
380 pages long
so the notion that we are now going to
have two checklists
two processes to follow
i i find mind-boggling and um
quite frustrating the other factor
that's occurring
at many polling places is it's getting
harder to find people to run for
supervisor
moderator and some of these tasks so be
aware that we do this because we
care but the harder you make it the
harder it will be to find people like us
to carry out this job
my second point is you've heard it many
times
confusion is used as a tool to keep
people away from the polls
there has been confusion built into the
process over the last 10 years with
every change that comes to the ballot
process someone asked earlier
do you know anyone who hasn't come well
think about that question
somebody who's been denied voting if
they haven't come to the door
how would i know that you know it's the
confusion
that causes them to pause and say well i
guess maybe i can't vote so
i hope it's clear that i oppose this
amendment i
highly support efforts to enable people
to vote
honestly and through a trustworthy
process
i do not believe this amendment has that
goal in mind
thank you mr chair thank you my
questions from mr ralph
yes you know and thank you very much for
your testimony
i also signed up to speak with kevin
twain
i do not see mr fleming on the attendee
list
um again if he's the phone number he
could raise his hand with star9
he does not appear to be here uh
also signed up to speak is jody nelson
is nelson are you with us
she is
barry
oops
there she is good morning is nelson
you're muted uh you've um
you have three minutes
you need one new
sorry about that i was having technical
difficulties at home thank you mr
chairman and members of the committee
for your time
my name is jody nelson from derry
out of respect for people's time i will
just state i am testifying in support of
this amendment
for all the reasons in favor that have
been noted prior to my testimony thank
you
thank you ms nelson are you taking
questions or
i'm not taking questions no no thank you
very much
thank you also signed up to speak this
morning
michael mr saber are you with us
i do not see mr seba
okay and then the last person who has
signed up the speaker this morning
ciao kelly ms kelly are you of us
i do not see her either
but we do have some additional hands
that have um
been raised uh amanda gokey
olivia zink and susan richman um
oh she it looks like she her hand is now
down
um
here she is um
good morning um here
and members of the committee um i am
testifying in opposition
of this amendment for the record my name
is olivia zink from franklin and i'm the
executive director of open democracy
action a nonpartisan nonprofit pro-voter
organization
h.r won the for the people act um passed
the
u.s house in march and on may 11
the senate rules committee
um did mark also one this is
this per this and the proposed
amendments are the largest democracy
reform bill in 50 years
this bill is a critical package of
reform that is supported by the
overwhelming majority of americans
across party lines
to get dark money out of politics crack
down on corruption
protect voting rights and ensure safe
accessible and accurate elections
according to a poll 83
of americans support this um and then
the campaign finance provisions
96 percent uh of democrats
74 percent of republicans and 73 percent
of
independents favor the for the people
voters nearly unanimously support
provisions to influence
to limit influence of big money in
politics ninety four percent of voters
support
um making political cr transparency
political contributions to be
fully disclosed also um providing more
transparency of lobbying
and and lobbying activity um
so these are really broad support across
the aisle
the for the people act does make make a
promise to our democracy and really
making sure we have
equitable rights these are national
standards
that set a floor their common sense
like automatic voter registration online
voter registration
same-day voter registration it has been
brought up earlier
that this impacts um photo id
requirements i urge you to read the bill
and not listen to the dark money
advertisements in new hampshire
this bill just says if you don't have a
photo id you have to sign an affidavit
which is what new hampshire does we take
their picture
people sign an affidavit so please read
the bill
and not listen to the dark money
advertisements this bill also
ends partisan gerrymandering by creating
an independent redistricting commission
i think we all can agree that voters
should be picking our representatives
and not our politicians picking
i'm getting big money out of politics
and combating corruption
it's very important that we do this this
amendment simply put
creates massive confusion and costs new
hampshire a lot of money
federal law cannot be nullified um
federal the federal government will run
federal elections
and creating a two-track system is
inappropriate therefore i
urge you to vote down this amendment and
are happy to take any questions
thank you any questions
seeing no questions thank you very much
for your testimony
also signed up to speak this morning um
susan
yes hello thank you um for taking my
testimony
i am speaking in opposition to the
non-german amendment 1445 to house bill
i worry there's been no financial note
uh for what exactly it may cost to run
two parallel election systems
who would then be responsible for
picking up the increased cost
and is this something else that will be
passed down to towns and cities to pay
additionally i have personal experience
working
in my town's elections a poll worker of
how very great the time commitment is
for our election officials before
election day during the very long day at
the polls
and then many steps to process records
afterwards
where will an extra workforce be found
to run two sets of elections and
in the case of paid workers how will
that be paid for
additionally it takes about 100
volunteers to fully staff our polls
is it likely that 100 volunteers will be
fined
will be found if there is going to be a
second
day of parallel elections if not then
as was mentioned before there's the
expense of a second
set of voting machines so either way
the resources either human or financial
will be considerable and there are so
many of these details that need to be
considered before a bill of this size
is allowed to move forward as it stands
now this bill
purpose seems to create an electric
an election process that is chaotic
which will then of course discourage
people from
voting at all so thank you for uh
listening to me and
i urge you please to um
not to pass this john germain amendment
1445 to house bill 89.
thank you thank you any questions for ms
richmond
see you guys thank you very much thank
you
um also signed up to speak is uh
terry lakeland
hopefully i'm pronouncing that correctly
you're with
thank you my name is kerry claflin and
i'm a supervisor of the checklist
in concord ward 5. um i've submitted
written testimony um several days ago to
this committee
so i'm not uh going to rehearse so much
of
what's been said that i do agree with
i'm speaking in
opposition to this amendment uh
for the many of the reasons that have
been talked about
i just want to add a couple of extra
things i really object
to the characterization of election
official attitudes toward s1
these comments this morning and earlier
um in the media have been
they're speculative there's been no
reliable polling done
um and to take um the
uh opinions of 24 only
24 town clerks uh who were
i don't know i don't know how they were
chosen were they called
uh were they chosen by the secretary of
state to get their opinion
uh i don't know that but i know that
i fully support um ss1
and uh while it's not a perfect bill i
agree with
others um who have said i think it's
incumbent upon
the the election elected officials in
this state
to you guys and the secretary of state
to reach out to
um our senators because what's going on
right now
is a markup and if you have concerns
if you have special needs that you want
to make sure
that you get on the record i urge you to
please
contact them and get involved in that
process
as opposed to on the back end
obstructing resisting and
putting out misinformation about this
bill
so just in closing i'll stress that this
amendment ignores the fact that not only
do
election officials want and support many
of these modernizations
in s1 but um it is very popular with
voters of all
political ideologies in my written
testimony i have
a couple of footnotes that tell you
where i
i've gotten my information about polling
i just uh some of that's been mentioned
but
um the polling data show that
implementing national standards for
elections
is far more popular with republican
democratic and independent voters
than so-called states rights thank you
so please do not needlessly complicate
our elections just despite the federal
government our crude of a point
it is the voters and the election
officials of new hampshire who will
surely suffer
thank you so much thank you questions
from his
classroom nice
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you
uh we also have linda bundy who wants to
speak is bundy
with us i've just promoted her and also
janet ward
um has has contacted me and would like
to speak
right hey
thank you good morning mr chairman and
members of the committee
i'm i'm from antrim i'm speaking
in opposition to the non-jermaine
amendment to
sb 89 if this passes we will have two
standards for
elections federal elections will be
conducted one way the new hampshire
constitution and new hampshire law will
apply to non-federal elections
to ballots to procedures and
requirements relating to
voter eligibility voter registration
absentee voting conducting the vote and
counting of votes
this will be confusing for voters and
serve as a barrier to voting for many
people
it will create additional work for
official election officials
establishing two separate systems will
incur
significant expenses the for the people
act will move election procedures
forward into the 21st century and allow
even more participation
by new hampshire voters i am confident
that our secretary of state would still
maintain secure
elections even as they become more
accessible
i support sb 89 but i urge the committee
members to vote against
this amendment thank you for your time
thank you any questions
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you
and janet ward uh you also wish to speak
yes she's been promoted and if she would
unmute herself
um that would be great janet ward
morning good morning um
just one moment
good morning to you i recently watched
the presentation offered by deputy
secretary of state david scanlon to the
new hampshire election officials
on the for the people act um during this
conversation
i suggested to mr scanlon that he
contact
our federal delegation with his concerns
regarding
uh s1 um i also
told uh mr scanlon that his
not his slideshow but his commentary on
the act
was as disingenuous and willfully
um blind to the critical objectives
of the for the people act as is this
non-germane amendment
to a good bill sb 89 which you are
considering today
i also watched the entirety of the
senate committee on the judiciary's
hearing
on the for the people act during which
new hampshire's secretary of state
also demonstrated what had to be willful
blindness regarding
the critical necessity of this
legislation
surely he and mr scanlon have witnessed
the multitude of voter suppression laws
being considered nationwide and must
appreciate
the need for the for the people act let
us be clear
before the people act was not designed
to disrespect states like new hampshire
which did an
admirable job of conducting safe and
fair elections
even during the pandemic as for the
letter sent to senator maggie hassan
by representatives ross berry and joe
sweeney
like the testimony of mr gardner in the
presentation by mr scanlon
it contains a deliberate failure to
acknowledge and document
critical voter suppression issues the
act was designed to address
as well as considerable misinformation
here are some of the key objectives of
the legislation
to ensure that billionaires and
corporate special interests cannot buy
our elections to directly address
corrupt practices which deny
legitimate voters their right to vote to
end the corrupt practice of
gerrymandering
the members of this committee are
charged with protecting the keystone of
our democracy
our right to vote there is no defensible
reason to support this non-germane
amendment
which would require totally unnecessary
financially costly and utterly confusing
separate sets of elections in general
thank you
elections this amendment would block
provisions that would protect
and enhance the rights of legitimate
voters such as automatic voter
registration
online voter registration and no excuse
absentee voting
which not only safeguarded the health of
voters but increased
voter participation in november please
support
89 and vote no on this amendment
and realize that you can reach out to
your federal delegation
and explain your concerns and as the
bill is being marked up
thank you any questions
yes thank you okay thank you uh
we're all set thank you ma'am i see no
one else uh
asking to testify family you're aware of
it but yes i see one of those
about harry mr perry
yes i've just um promoted him thank you
thank you manager and members of the
committee
first off i'd like to have my written
testimony
which i submitted last night reflecting
that i'm speaking
on sb 89 hb 89
i speak in support of 89 but i speak in
opposition to amendment 1445 h
s 1 is a federal bill that sets minimum
standards for conducting of elections
this bill is vehemently opposed by big
money interests even as 47 states
advance 350 restrictive voting rights
bills
that ignore the successful voter turnout
in the november
election among the many big money tv and
social media ads opposing s1
that i have encountered i conclude they
all take full advantage of the doctrine
of lying as protected speech
the effect of this amendment is to
reject the minimum standards for voting
in america's elections generally
and specifically ensuring that
manipulation of political districts
to benefit the majority party remains a
viable
option it pits states rights against
voting rights
we are a not so united united states of
america
the sham so-called audit by the cyber
ninja partisan amateurs
currently taking place in arizona
directly affects election results in the
other 49 states
in presidential elections and
demonstrates the absolute
need for federal minimum standards for
elections
ensuring that ordinary voters have a
fighting chance
against moneyed interests hell-bent
on overturning an election
thankfully the arizona board of
supervisors several days ago
released a symbolic cease and desist
order to followers of the big lie
it reads in part it's time to end this
for the good of the senate for the good
of the country and for the good of the
democratic institutions
that define us as americans
i join in their protestations i join
with the majority of americans who
support s-1
i oppose the efforts of moneyed interest
that do not value the successful
and historic voter turnout in november
made possible through the expansion of
opportunities to participate
in the franchise i respectfully but
strongly urge
this amendment be defeated thank you and
i'll take no questions
i am not i do see representative lane
has her hand up but that's the only hand
i see
wayne oh thank you uh mr chair i was
just wondering
if uh you had stated
or if you would state what the uh
sign in tallies were on this uh
amendment
are these deciding tallies 307 in
support 331 in opposition
neutral one in total to testify with 20
initially
thank you well with no one else asking
to testify
i'm going to declare this hearing closed
i thank you everyone out for your
your indulgence and i would invite
chairman griffin back to the chair
why don't we take a break till 11 30.
sorry representatives
all right we are unmuted and our video
is on it is
11 30. um thank you to the election law
committee for
the attending attendance this morning at
the public hearing
we are back after recess as noticed
in the house calendar we have senate
bills that remain before us to be
acted on the and we're going to go
through those senate bills in order
and the first bill we have is sb
31 relative to voter checklist
and modifying the absentee
ballot affidavit this
bill was modifying supervisors of the
checklist
actions and dealt with providing voter
information
from the secretary of state and
the cities and towns
the committee has received so members of
the public are aware
a number of proposed amendments
and i am open to any amendments which
have not
yet been distributed if anybody has them
i am not aware
of any representative lane i see you
have your hand open
his hand up it's open too
i just was wondering since this is a
separate hearing do we have to go
through
we're present we're by ourselves all
that's do we need to go through those
protocols
i just don't want all this work to go
for naught and have somebody come back
later and say we didn't do it i'm hoping
pam is back in her office
i don't think so pam do we need to do
another roll call for attendance
and do the whole opening again um
we have when we've changed the type of
meeting
i don't know a hard and fast you know
requirement for it
but might the other committees i've
worked with have just to be
on the safe side they have repeated the
roll call
and the and the opening announcement
opening announcement
all right um but not all the not all
those you know the discussion of the
mics and everything but
all right um well thank you
representative lane for that question
and thank you
to cam smarling for clarifying that
other committees have done that
in light of the fact that we are now in
a different
mode we have gone from public hearing to
executive session
um i will say that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the program 19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order 12.
there's two incidents second
this body is authorized to meet
electronically in regards
to the matter scheduled in the house
calendar for today it matters we will be
addressing our executive sessions
on the senate please note that there is
no physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
where i am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom
electronic leading platform and the
public takes access to contemporaries
listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar
general website the notice for this
meeting complies with house rules
in new hampshire rsa 91k anyone who has
a following
accessing meeting you should call 271
3600 or email
hcs at ledge.state.nh.us
is unable to access this meeting meeting
will be a journal
and all
and i'm assuming i'm not hearing from
anybody that there's a problem this
microphone has been dutifully moved back
and forth up here at the table
but is not on so
i'm going to leave it in its current
state as long as
everything is proceeding all right it's
hard to keep hearing and i'm not seeing
any issue with that so having said that
i'm going to ask the clerk
representative wells to call the world
representative bergeron uh i am
president i'm participating remotely
from my home in nashua
representative barry i am president in
the committee remain congress
representative cody i am here in my home
in nashua
representative freitas i am here in my
home in manchester
madam chair i'm president
representative growing up president in
the
committee room in concord representative
hamblet
i am present in my home in portsmouth
and my son is in another room
representative hamer i'm present
in my home in manchester
representative hayward president
representative lane i am present
in my home in concord my husband is in
another room
representative mcdonald our president at
the committee women's
office representative mooney here at the
lob
representative murrah present in hanover
new hampshire
alone representative fruit home o'brien
i'm here in coffee
i'm here in the committee meeting room
i'm talking representative sandler
representative sandler i am in my home
office
in somersworth uh my husband and our
cats are on the
lower level of the house representative
sweeney
president representative terozian
i'm president of the committee
here in fort smith's family member in
the house and
i'm having real trouble hearing
particularly madam chair and other
people in the committee room all right
i'm going to try and turn the
turn the mic in front of me off so i'm
going to need some separate thumbs down
as we proceed
all right that concludes the roll call
so uh as i started to say and was
thankfully interrupted in regards to
notices
the first bill before the committee
as noticed in the calendar
is sb 31 relative to checklists
and the absentee ballot envelopes um
there was an amendment sent to committee
members
2021 14 86
can someone have a motion representative
representative hayward i move that
we take off the amendment 15 h6h
the motion representative hayward would
you like to speak to your motion
thank you madam chair this amendment
eliminates
the amendment because it's an
elimination
of a sentence amendment does not show
that sentence
look at your original version
on page three encompass department line
and it is the result of that amendment
to put
the statute in consistent with
its current form
yes all right
questions on the amendment
representative bergeron
uh thank you madam chair uh
representative hayward
uh al although the pandemic
um resulted in
in the changes i suppose to the
understanding of what constitutes a
disability
the attorney general's memo joint memo
with the secretary of state
uh on absentee ballot re uh absentee
ballot requesting
eligibility stated
had this conclusion absentee voting is
permitted in any circumstance
where the voter is under medical advice
whether it is individualized advice or
general advice to the public
to avoid being in places like a polling
place
so my question is i i have family
members one of who
had an organ transplant another who was
in stage four cancer and
are under the advice of their doctors to
avoid large gatherings of people
is it your intent to deny those people
the right to request an absentee ballot
so that they can avoid going to public
places
that is not my intent at all but
the action as it currently exists
under the emergency boards
unrelated to the
standard process that we are
talking about here if there's a
requirement
that a mass
an emergency order such as we are
currently
experiencing and that is a separate
item of one-off
sort of circumstance rather than the
general services
further question madam chair
representative representative hayward
there's nothing in the original bill or
your amendment that says anything to do
with masks it just talks about
medical conditions and in the case of
the attorney general's uh
memo it talks about a person should have
the right
to request a ballot if they receive
individual advice or general advice
related to their medical condition to
avoid going to
public areas like like a polling place
in other words this is not covid
specific it is not
an emergency order specific it deals
with any
example or situation where someone might
have a medical condition that
should enable them to obtain an absentee
ballot
and may i just interject that that
representative hayward
it's it's your voice is relatively soft
and and if you could be
near a microphone it would be helpful
okay i'm i'm now very near on microphone
oh
we're uh i
uh i did not talk about masks at all so
i i hope that wasn't
uh a part of
what what you heard
i think just for clarification there is
the
the law of pre-statute there is the
emergency order
and then there is a separate
representative bergeron i believe you're
referring to a separate memorandum that
was
issued in regards to the status of
elections that
was not specifically part of the
emergencies
correct i'm referring to a memo dated
april 10 2020 relative to elections
operations during
the state of emergency correct and i i
understand
representative hayward's going to be it
was operative during his state of
emergency
okay thank you thank you
other questions or comments from
many committee members and i i will say
that
during the break i pondered that it is
actually
much more interesting to sit on the side
in these
in these meetings to sit in the front of
the room managing it so
there you go i had my morning off
representative lane
um thank you madam chair i i could
hardly hear
what representative hayward said so if
he could just
keep his answer to representative
bergeron's because i'm still not clear
on why the sentence needed to be deleted
i also had great difficulty hearing his
response thank you
i would say rather than try and
re-answer
if i return back to the beginning
because representative bergeron's
question
really related to a different document
than we are
working on that
my amendment to
sb-31 is part which will become part of
the rsa
uh eliminates a pandemic only sentence
that is out of place in this disability
question
and it's worded so vaguely that it is
unnecessary as an exception in
the normal or standard context
thank you representative
other members
can i have a follow-up please i'm sorry
um i guess i don't see anything about
the pandemic
in the original language it just talks
about
a medical condition that poses a risk of
infection
so it it's not necessarily related to
covert or pandemic it just says that
in the example he gave if someone's in
stage four cancer
and they've been told by their doctor
not to vote
not to go into public places to vote
under
without that language i'm not sure that
they qualify
as a disability that's that's why
i i like the language is because it made
it clear
it wasn't related at all thank you
representative
i think the difference in position is
noted um i do not recall
hearing any testimony and i did not do
the senate testimony of the public
hearing on this
for anybody who had such a condition
which should have been
pretty pandemic certainly and as to
representative bergeron's
example that uh felt that the law
required them to vote
in place and that they wouldn't qualify
under the language of disability
as it existed prior to the pandemic
i i certainly have some concerns about
it because
of the generic
nature of it in regards to you know
polling places in the winter and the
same risk class for covid certainly is
the same risk path for something such as
the flu
and no i don't want to get into whether
you should be in or out with the flu
but i think that for me
that was something certain i didn't have
any issues with the fact that i felt
that somebody in representative bergeron
situation
would qualify as being disabled and
certainly would have been
under a condition where they were not
able to leave their house for health
reasons under any circumstances
given that the risk of infection was so
strong
having some familiarity with people in
the treatment
other questions or comments from
committee members representative cody
thank you ma'am chad i guess i'm i'm
still trying to figure out what
what representative hayward's intent is
all right thank you
any further discussion on the proposed
amendment
um also committee members just for a
process
if bills are amended today they will go
to a committee of
conference um i think
if after if they are passed by the house
at session
on june 3rd or 4th i think we're meeting
our fourth or fifth i can't remember
amended bills that pass the house will
go to a committee of conference
i believe the committee conference is
the following
week i believe those committee
conferences are intended to be hybrid
and for purposes of amendment on what we
would refer to as our senate omnibus
bills
if a section of a bill is
removed or amended either in any bill
or as an on the bus bill that will not
go to the floor to be voted on which
means
it can be brought forward again
in the second year of this session
so that's just a little procedural note
in regards to changes that could
get made to bills this year the first
year
of the session excuse me madam chair but
isn't
we don't know anything about whether the
senate will concur with
with any of these amendments do we i
mean yeah
the committee of conference would only
occur if the senate requested one and
the house
acceded to one so we
really don't know that at this point do
we
thank you representative cody i really i
don't i don't certainly know the senate
position on any of these
so thank you for that clarification
given the year
all right is there any further
discussion on this amendment
seeing none i'm going to call for a vote
on amendment to sb 31 which is
on the floor 2021 14
86 8 i'm going to ask her to
representative mcdonald yes
representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney
yes representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes representative
yes representative barry yes
representative crowing yes
representative quality
yes clerk is yes
representative cody no
representative ward no
representative no representative sandler
no representative hamer
no representative lane
representative lane zarya had trouble
unmuting
uh actually yes
representative freitas yes
representative hamlet no envelope
representing your head no
matter cheer yes okay
13 to 7. the amendment carries 13
to 7 are there any further amendments
that anyone wants to bring
forward related to sb 31
i'm sorry it's 12-8 12-8
vote on the amendment 1486h was 12 to 8.
i'm seeing no
further amendments is there a motion
peter thank you madam chair i recommend
i move that we ought to pass with
amendments
sb 31.
representative kweily seconds it further
discussion on the motion
oh sure
i'm going to ask the clerk to call the
role
representative mcdonald yes
representative prudhomme o'brien yes
representative sweeney
yes representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes representative yes representative
barry
yes representative growing yes
representative whaley
yes clark is yes representative cody
no representative ward
no where's you're on
no representative sandler
no representative hamer
no representative lane
yes representative freitas
no
representative hamlet yes
representing your head no
[Music]
that's 12 to 8. the motion carries 12 to
sb 31 has been passed as amended
14 86 h
37 13 to 7 i believe okay
you know i believe that representative
friedas was recorded
as a yes vote on the amendment but not
but not
on the overall vote i'm not sure she
intended to do that because i recall
hearing her
say oh no at one point um
but i think that is what the votes are
is anybody have any other clarification
my understanding is that all republicans
and one democrat voted for the bill as
amended
two democrats representative a
representative hamlet did you vote
for or against that bill i voted for the
bill
okay all right thank you so it was
thirteen to seven
all right so oh cause i didn't call you
that's why
i say mata
i have my hand up i'm sorry we were
trying to straighten out the boat here
representative friedas
yes i would like i would like to change
my vote to yes
okay thank you
so there will be three democrat yes
votes you representative lane and
representative
cameron and i'm seeing nods of agreement
what's past that title correct
what was i doing
all right the next bill
before us this morning is sb 46.
sb 46 is relative to the use of
electronic pole vaults by cities and
towns
it had a public hearing before this
committee
on march 31st
is there a motion representative
yes madam chairman i moved that we ought
to pass sb 46.
representative sweeney bennett seconded
that
it's been moved and seconded to pass sb
46.
would you like to speak to your motion
representative barry uh yes ma'am
chairman
very briefly i'm a big fan of electronic
poll books i'm a big fan
of modernizing our elections i believe
that electronic poll books
in the long run will create shorter
lines on election day because as
most large uh voting places we go in
names are segregated
by the last the last first
and that creates a problem on election
day because very often
um there's nobody in the a to b line of
people who are in through you know
whatever
s have a line backed up electronic pull
books that problem is gone
now it's just a matter of how many how
many workers do we have there they can
process any one regardless of their last
name
so it'll decrease waiting times on
election day
further discussion on the motion on the
floor
which is otp as to sb 46
representative cody um
can you hear me madam chair
uh yes i would just like to say i'm very
happy to see this
advancing having sat here during a good
portion of our earlier work on
electronic flow books it's nice to see a
positive motion and i will be supporting
it thank you
everybody
i'm not seeing any so i'm going to ask
support to follow the rule
the motion on the floor is otps
representative macdonald yes
representative
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward
yes representative mooney yes
representative torosium yes
representative barry
yes representative growing yes
representative quayley
yes marcus yes representative cody
yes representative ward
yes representative bergeron
yes representative sandler
yes representative hamer
yes representative lane
yes representative freitas
yes representative hamblet
yes representative murrahab yes
madam chair yes
on otp sb46 was
20 to 0
if there's no objection that will go on
the consent
calendar
so that will be consent
sc 54 is the next bill in front of this
committee this is relative to the
absentee ballot application form the
public hearing
on this bill was march 31st
is there a motion on sb 43
representative derozan to make a motion
madam chair to
retain senate bill 54.
i second that madam chair representative
rowan
seconds it would you like to speak to
your motion representative
yes thank you madam chair i was
mentioned to bill i like that
still some things need to be sorted out
since the reason to retain the bills to
work on it
um have to do with identification
and uh on the last page of the bill
under
or talks about
one of them is um any other information
or records that the town clerk may
verify
so some of this needs to be kind of
defined and i'm confident
uh retaining the bill we can work this
out uh
to bring something back that's uh more
specific
that's all i have is there further
discussion on this motion which is to
retain i would
also just point out that this committee
has retained
i think a parallel or similar bill hb
representative cody
somewhat along the lines of the previous
speaker
i have some problems with some of this
but it's certainly
i certainly agree that it is a good
candidate for retention it has some
serious problems over and above those
that
that i'm referring to so i will be
voting to retain the bill
thank you thank you for any further
discussion on the bill
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the roll the motion on the floor
is to retain
representative mcdonald yes
representative
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes representative tarosian yes
representative barry yes representative
growing
yes representative whaley yes
clerk is yes representative cody
yes representative ward yes
represent representative bergeron yes
representative sandler
yes representative hamer yes
representative lane yes
representative freitas yes
representative hamlet yes representative
yes okay 20 to 0.
sb 54 is retained
the next bill before us this morning
up this afternoon is sb 83
sv 83 had a public hearing on april
23rd this is
our first consideration of an omnibus
bill
from the senate it has five parts as we
did so during the public hearing
i'm going to proceed through these
anonymous bills by part
taking motions by part looking for
a motion at the end of the
considerations of the individual parts
for the motion as a whole
so part one of sb
83 deals with the qualification of
certain persons from performing duties
as an election official
there is an amendment that has been sent
to the committee
it is amendment number 2021
1481 is there a motion
representative mcdonald moves in 1481
each is there a second i second that
madam chair
representative rowan seconds it
representative mcdonald would you like
to speak to your motion
yes ma'am chairman
while we understand some of the concerns
about potential conflicts of interest
and so forth
uh the fact is that moderators and
traders in particular have a
constitutional duty as a numerator
specified in the enhanced state
constitution to
perform their function there is no
provision for them to do otherwise
they have these responsibilities it's
not clear to delegate them
and uh regardless of what office they
might be seeking
problematic that they've been
disqualified or
in some way limited we've heard from the
secretary of state he's indicated
there's not been a problem and
by all indications all moderators have
acted
appropriately balanced issues that means
that i have produced this event
is there any further discussion on this
amendment
i would just like to clarify i do think
we heard that there are people who have
raised this
as an issue what this means is that
moderators can be present within the
guard rail
but they are on the ballot for a
different
for any office and there
are puppet complaints made but
it is a issue that we have been
grappling with for many sessions and
it's just not clear
to me that this is the right solution
any further discussion representative
cody
um yes i'll be i'll be opposing the
amendment because i've always felt that
if you're on the ballot you don't need
to be anywhere near
the accounting of ballots thank you
any further discussion
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the rule the motion on the floor
is otp
1481.
representative mcdonald yes
representative
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes representative yes representative
barry
yes representative growing yes
representative yes yes representative
cody
representative cody if we could see you
for your no vote please
hold on one second madam chair just
getting with the program here i don't
think anybody have any question as to
what's going on
there you are thank you okay all right
representative ward
no representative bergeron
no representative sandler
representative sandler representative
sandler don't see her
i think she dropped off all right maybe
she'll call back in
continue with the role representative
hamer
no representative lane
no representative freitas
no representative handler
no representative your head
no adam chair
yes
[Music]
i just want to ask again is
representative sandler on the line
pam i'm showing a dan mason but that's
just somebody who's showing up for being
on the zoom right
yes i don't know why he's showing up on
your screen he's not in the
panelist list you know he's in the knees
so it's um
that's all right that happens
occasionally i just wanted to
make sure that wasn't representative
sandler by another name
he would make an excellent committee
member though madam chair
i think he would be very valuable to me
all right
part all right any other motions on part
one of
sd83 okay
part two of
sb 83 is
deals with the establishment of an
election information
portal there is an amendment that has
been proposed in regards to part
two is there a motion
hospital
yes thank you madam chair while there
are parts of this that certainly have
merit
and if this was a separate bill we
retained work on it
because it is about bill we can't do
that
and where we heard testimony that
there is no we know there's no fiscal
note on it over here
is there any further discussion on the
amendment representative
um i would be curious as to other than
the date
in which was uh january 1st 2002
what the other provisions are that were
problematic
i'd be glad to speak to everybody thank
you
um the time to implement was one of them
and the other was
the fact that it needs to go to
informational
new hampshire i.t department and so i
don't
believe their equipment this time to do
this so based on some testimony we had
on this
so for those reasons
is there further discussion on it
and as representative points out
things that are deleted but not voted on
by the house floor
main items to be considered by the house
i'm not seeing any further discussion on
the bill i'm going to ask the club
sba 3 number 14 adh
representative mcdonald yes
representative
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
representative yes representative mooney
yes representative yeah
representative barry yes representative
growing
yes representative quality yes
clerk is yes representative cody no
representative ward no representative
bergeron
no representative sandler no
representative hamer no
representative lane no
representative freitas no
representative hamlet no representative
your head
no is that a yes
no that's a no okay madam cheer
yes okay don't worry representative
so eleven to nine so uh 1480
h has passes 11
to 9.
the next section of sb
83 is part
to three these
is there any buddy who has
any amendment to part
three of sbe three
discussion on part three
i'm not seeing any so i'm going to move
on to part
four part four is
relative to statements filed by
political committees
and candidates
[Music]
the committee should committee members
should have an amendment
in front of them which should
[Music]
is there a second i second the motion
promotion is separated by representative
wells representative barry would you
like to speak to your motion
yes ma'am chairman um this this highly
controversial
amendment um makes the minimum
submission
for a online or facsimile a copy
of a key of a finance report it takes a
programmable eight point font
to a minimum of 12.5 because i have any
older
my eyes
is there any further discussion
on these amendments amendment numbers
11.88
madam chair i couldn't hear the motion
representative ward it's 1188h
yeah i got that to increase the font
size if you're looking at the original
bills
yeah i got that it events
was it otp or itl i couldn't hear his
motion no no
no the motion is to amend the eight
point
font size to 12.
seems like government overreach to me
but
[Music]
the nanny state strikes again
[Laughter]
not bad
all right is there any further
discussion on the amendment which is
on the floor it is 11.88
78 all right i'm not seeing any further
discussion
i'm going to ask the clerk to call the
role representative mcdonald
yes representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward
yes representative mooney yes
representative yeah representative barry
yes representative growing yes
representative quality
yes representative cody
20 years ago i would have voted no but i
vote yes
representative ward oh
sirius representative bergeron
yes representative sandler
yes representative hamer yes
representative lane yes
representative freitas yes
representative hamlet yes representative
your head
yes madam chair yes in 1921.
both here is 19 to 1
11 18 h has passed it's an amendment to
section
part 4 of sb 83 are there any further
rules
in regards to part 4.
i'm seeing none part five
of sb 83 is related to town
meeting procedures
it should have received amendment
proposed amendment number
14 17 h
is there a motion madam chair i move
that we pass
amendment 2021 1417
to sb 83. is there a second
the second the most bad fear
representative in the second set
representative would you like to speak
to your motion yes thank you madam chair
the current language in section 5
refers it changed the
word years year apostrophe s
two years which is s apostrophe
and that left some uncertainty as to
which
fiscal year was referred to whether it
was the immediately
conceding fiscal year or if it was any
preceding fiscal year this amendment
clarifies that by
simply stating that it's for
appropriations and expenditures which
were approved for the same purposes
for the immediately preceding fiscal
period
thank you representative lane you have
your hand up
uh yes i i would have a question the
last word of the amendment
um should it not be year instead of
period
i i understand you know the purpose of
the amendment and what we're
but based on the conversations that we
were having i just thought it might be
better to be consistent
to use the word fiscal year instead of
fiscal period
since we haven't really used that before
and it's not used in other parts of the
statute
to my knowledge
i can speak to that you can go ahead
the in the case of towns they are
single fiscal years uh in
the the fiscal period in this case will
always refer
to a fiscal year because that is what
the towns refer to
we could have used the language either
way i could have put that in but
that's this is what i received from
the legislative services and it does
refer to
in this case a fiscal year because
that's what all the towns operate
i i agree with attorney claim that it
might have been here but i think that we
were trying to get away
from the confusion and ols might have
taken it to an
extra degree but i think it's
understandable
i don't think there's any questions
as to what the intent was
is there any further discussion on this
amendment
yes representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayward
yes representative mooney yes
representative
yes representative perry yes
representative growing
yes representative yes
yes represent cody no
representative ward no
representative bergeron no
representative sandler no
representative hamer no
representative blaine no
representative freitas no
representative hamlet no
representative your head no
11 to 9 shareholders yes
yeah i'm sorry
all right the the amendment passes 11 to
9.
is there are there any further emotions
in regard to
sb 83
otp on senate bill 83 as i mentioned
second and the amendments you're
referring to
are and the amendments i'm referring
[Music]
would you like to speak to your motion
representative thank you madam chair
and jerry i believe uh you know we knew
we first got these
bills that challenged sometimes to be
able to
uh was some reaction from some people
just to
die you know i think the best that we
could do
modifying or amending the bill to pass
the good parts out of the bill
just to kind of go over a quick uh
summary on part one
you guys just want disqualifying people
from election officials tom level while
i agree
with some of my colleagues on this that
i don't like to see something funny for
obviously in that position
i can tell you in one of my towns in my
district both the
moderator there we go moderator and the
assistant moderator of both uh house
members
and further the fact that the
constitution is very clear on that
we really couldn't uh
good conscience change that i gave the
reasons on section two
so i um that we should delete that
anybody in the house is free to bring
forward that bill as a separate bill
going forward the next year we got to
uh recount fees
that brings those fees in line makes it
more responsible
for costs associated still probably
doesn't cover
all the costs but at least it covers
more and in regard to
itemized statements by political
candidates
it the amendment certainly makes
reports more legible readable uh
if you have to file the reports they
certainly ought to be readable
and lastly the last section providing
for actual town meeting procedures
we heard this was needed to
the towns that are on a fiscal year not
a calendar year and particularly in this
covered year where
sometime meetings were later in the year
um i think it was a great common sense
amendment
that it simply clarified what was
somewhat of a vague statement
that requires uh
the purposes of appropriations and
expenditures were
which were approved for the same purpose
purposes for
the immediate immediately proceeding
fiscal
period it makes it clear it was somewhat
vague and not quite clear before
so for all those reasons i uh made the
motion
and i hope you support the motion to otp
senate bill 83 is amended thank you
thank you representative does anybody
else wish to speak to the amendment
i mean the motion on the floor which is
sb 83 is amended
i'm
yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward
yes representative mooney yes
representative
yes representative barry yes
representative growing
yes representative whaley yes
yes representative cody yes
ward yes representative bergeron
yes representative sandler yes
representative hamer yes representative
lane
yes representative freitas
yes representative hamlet yes
representative your head yes madam chair
yes
if there's no objection sb 83 will go
from the consent now
thank you the next and last bill before
the committee's for consideration this
year
is sb 89 just had
a public hearing on april 23rd
and it had a public hearing today on a
non-journey
amendment this was on the bus
legislation relative to election
procedure
and registration registrar's excuse me
from probate
from this came out of the senate
election law and municipal affairs
committee
as we did with 83 for sb 89 we will go
through by
parts part 1 has to do with the city
chief
elections officers are there
comments or i'm not aware of but there
may be
amendments part one of
sb 89
i'm not seeing any so we will move on to
part two of the sp
i'm not aware of any amendments do does
any member have an amendment
any
sb 89
deals with primarily the processing of
pre-processing of dallas
uh thank you madam chair i'd like to uh
propose amending
senate bill 89 with the amendment
2021-1255-h
and would like to speak to that motion
is there a second
representative i'll second that
cody this was an amendment that was
prepared and
the committee has previously spoken to
representative virgil
thank you madam chair um i'll be quick
cause we did discuss this previously
what the amendment tries to do is
preserve senator gray's intent
that absentee ballot applications and
affidavit envelopes
would be examined for every election
every municipal and state election
in an effort to try and determine if a
voter's paperwork was
filled out improperly and to make an
effort to try and contact the folder to
give them an opportunity to cure
their their affidavit ballot to use the
court's language and senator gray's
language
but we did have problems with some of
the logistics involved in making this
happen
and those are what i tried to address in
the amendment
for example um on page 2
lines 20 to 27 in the original bill
there was a provision that the clerk
should have to post a time and location
of every
time that this review would occur within
24 hours
prior to the review but in the same
paragraph it says that anytime
someone's voting in person that review
takes place
immediately there's also a provision
that
a review would be taken place at five
o'clock the night after five o'clock the
night before
an election um even if
there were problems with ballast would
be no way to contact the person to have
that
uh corrected because the offices would
be closed election day is the next day
and the absentee voter would have to
presumably go to the polls to vote
um because there would be no way for
them to make the correction on it
um and finally under state law it's the
moderator who makes the final
determination
as to whether or not the paperwork was
properly uh
completed not the clerk so that also was
addressed in the amendment
that's the the purpose of the amendment
to try and preserve
senator gray's primary intent but try
and
make it in a logistically feasible
make it a logistically feasible process
is there further discussion on the
amendment
um uh i'm before i ask the third party
i'm going to say that i appreciate
representative bergeron's
attempt to clear up some issues with
that
part of sb 89 because i do think it does
clean it up but i think that the
pre-processing process
itself is brought with issues
and i have serious concerns and
reflected to go forward with the process
that as a member of the
secure elections committee last year
were recommended for because of the
pelvic pandemic
but it was specific discussion and i
certainly made it clear that that
recommendation was for the
kobit issue that the case was
the state was addressing and i don't
think that the current practice
makes sense going forward so
i i just want to make it clear on the
record that i do think while
representative bergeron's
commitment might clean up some pieces of
it
i have issues with the part of the bill
i'm going to ask the clerk to call the
role representative rowan
could i add a comment that i also like
much of what's in here my main concern
with section 3
is that i believe it
creates classes of voters those that
have their balance corrected
basically voters who knows they can't
and for that reason i cannot pay for a
section three
[Music]
just a quick comment uh thank you
soundcheck
when we have a different situation in
the world
where covet is not as high as a concern
the concerns addressed in this bill and
this
bill will dissipate and so
we can revisit that if we find the big
challenge
any further discussion all right i'll
ask the third to call the world map
no representative sweeney no
representative hayward no representative
rooney
no representative terezian no
representative barry no representative
growing
no representative
representative cody yes
representative ward yes
representative bergeron yes
representative sandler yes
representative hamer yes representative
lane
yes representative freitas
she i believe she's left for a while she
had to leave
thank you representative hamlet yes
representative your head
representative your head you can unmute
sorry yes
eleven eleven to seven
excuse me is it eleven to seven or seven
two eleven
one two three six seven
eight eight yes eight
two the motion fails
we also have amendment 13 23
h to part three their emotion
uh yes ma'am chairman uh i move
amendment 13 23 h
ought to pass representative barry moves
13 23
sacrifices representatives
to your motion representative ma'am
jimmy very briefly um as actually
mentioned
in representative bergeron's um some
commentary
representative bergeron's amendment um
the pre-processing processes itself
rife with issues um i do for the record
appreciate representative bergeron's
hard work on that um
that was good faith and well well
executed
unfortunately pre-processing does create
different classes of voters
great classes of voters who send in
they're absolutely valid a month out it
creates a class of voters
um with voters and their absolute ballot
without time to be looked at
as i said when we were doing the hearing
on this omnibus bill
i have a i am a firm believer that
in new hampshire
as much of election day has to happen on
election day as possible
we're using i'm aware the municipal
association have asked for this for some
time
but for the most part we've been using
the pandemic as the excuse to bring this
forward
acting as if there's going to be all
these absentee ballots forever going on
uh in perpetuity and the reality is we
will begin to return to normal
we will have a midterm election uh our
very capable
uh election workers will be able to
handle this
and we're going to find other ways to
free them up on election day we just
moved forward
um electronic poll books that will free
up people to handle uh
absolute ballots on election day so we
should be new hampshire we do election
on election day
and that's the point of my amendment is
we're going to keep election on election
day
is there further discussion
representative ward
representative ward you have your
handout sorry that was a
mistake for any further discussion
on the amendment it is amendment number
2021 1323 page
representative cory uh yes ma'am i'll be
opposing the amendment
because i i happen to believe that if we
can give our hard-working local
officials
an opportunity to pre-process ballots we
ought to do that
and we ought to fix the problems that
exist and we attempted to do that as
well
and that's why i'll be voting no thank
you
further discussion
seeing none i'm going to ask the court
i'm going to ask the clerk to call the
vote
the motion on the floor is amendment
to sb 89 amendment number
2021 13 23 here
mcdonald yes representative
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes representative
representative ferry yes representative
growing
yes representative whaley yes clerk is
yes representative cody no
representative ward no representative
bergeron
no representative sandler no
representative hamer no
representative lane now representative
freitas
are there any further motions
on part three
let's see now i'm going to move on to
part four
part four is in regards as entitled
establishing a committee to study
post-election
audit accounting devices and
further authorizations in regards to
audits and
recounts i
have amendment number 1505
i don't have any other amendments to
this section
do i have a motion representative i have
a motion madam chair
food amendment 2021 1505
h is there a second
second that madam chair representative
hayward second said
would you like to speak to your motion
representative certainly madam chairman
thank you
so here's a concept from the part four
the title talk force establishing a
committee to study post-election audit
counting devices so what
this amendment does is it makes it the
study committee to do just what the
title says
while there were certain aspects other
aspects of that sector that i'd like
there was some contradictions that there
was also
um some cases that gave he brought her
powers and
the legislator intended to do uh he
granted a tremendous amount of power to
the attorney general's office
and it seems to me the best way to
address this issue is to study
come up with something that's uh i think
written a little bit better than
this section was in its entirety hence
the reason to
amend it let's start with the study
committee and
see where it takes us thank you
representative bergeron now thank you
madam chair
i'm going to vote in opposition to the
proposed amendment primarily
because and i i understand which
provisions of that section that
represents erosion is referring to and
in some ways i agree with him on that
aspect of it but the secretary of
state's office just recently conducted a
study of the use of high-speed optical
digital scanned ballot counting devices
and i have yet to hear a good
justification as to why we need another
study group to do
essentially the same thing it's uh its
effect will really be to delay the
implementation of any kind of
post-election
audit counting uh another year and i
don't see
a valid reason for just continuing to
kick this issue
down the road it's it's time to start
making these post-election audits happen
and therefore i can't support
another study committee on top of a
study committee that just finished its
work
further discussion
i i will just say i i myself was a
little confused on the study committee i
believe last year's study committee was
senator graydell and as
representative bergeron has provided the
committee with a report from that
however in light of this happening with
the state my hope is if
the committee goes forward it generates
a report they are capable of doing it
before november 30th
and there are i suspect other bills that
will be recommending things to go
forward for the second year of this
session
further comments on this amendment the
amendment
is 1505 h and it's to
sp89 part four
i'm seeing none so i'm going to ask
support to
yes representative o'brien yes
representative sweeney yes
representative hayworth
yes representative mooney yes
representation
yes representative perry yes
representative brown
yes representative yes clark is yes
representative cody no representative
ward
oh representative bergeron no
representative sandler no representative
hamer
no representative lane no
represent freitas not here
representative hamblet
no let's send your head
no madam chair
yes
there any further motions or discussion
on part four of
sb 89
so i'm going to move on to part five
part five of sb
89 is relative to the duties of the
registrar
of probate i do
have an amendment committee members
should also
have an amendment amendment number
representative mcdonald
on 1390 each to amend and test the
89 is there a second a second
it's been seconded by representative
wells is
representative mcdonald would you like
to speak to your motion
excuse me madam chair i'm having great
difficulty hearing representative
mcdonald
sorry about that
can you hear me now representative cody
very well actually okay i feel like i'm
doing a cell phone commercial can you
hear me can you give me that
but uh thank you for bringing that to my
attention though
um again the uh the current system
regarding
this whole probate issue with the paid
and carefully and well-trained
photographer probate has been working
very well in the last decade since it
was passed
uh this bill in particular this
amendment to try to reverse that
should have a fiscal note it does not
there's a question about whether it
would
generate the funding provision would be
effective
there's no training for what individual
who is often just the party activist of
either party
there's no indication that person would
be qualified or be properly trained once
they came in
there's no staff to help this person
once they arrive there's no office
for them to sit in and i know that it's
in the constitution that's been a
concern
but there have also been numerous
attempts to remove it from the
constitution which
i would encourage continue uh also this
is not even
something appropriate to election month
so that's another thing that i think we
should consider
is there any further discussion on part
four i
why don't you leave it sort of more
towards you so for some reason my voice
gets picked up alright
so we'll leave it
any further discussion that's right
representative barry uh yes um i am
ultimately going to be
supporting this amendment but
it's very not i'm not excited about it
i am a big proponent of turning this
position back to the people
i think people should have the ability
to seek redress when possible
and the judiciary system is designed as
i said
in the testimony the hearings the
judiciary system is designed to be
immovable
i do not like that
this this position whether we like it or
not
is in our state's constitution attempts
to remove it from the state constitution
have failed which should be a message
people want this unfortunately
this part of this only bill really has
no business part of election law
it really should have gone to judiciary
or to municipal accounting
and i am i'm not deaf to the political
reality that is basically
89 overall fail because the
issue of the registrar of probate has
typically been nonpartisan
so you'll take election law bills which
tend to go down by party milo
to thank everybody for the font size
increased earlier
and then attack on a non-partisan issue
inside of it
effectively so i'm going to vote
in favor of this amendment but i want to
state for the record i believe that
people elect the registrar that
registrar should have duties consider
constitution
and we don't like that we should
actually remove it from the constitution
further discussion
i too uh troubled that
that those duties went over to the
serving court and then
they're not being done at the county
level where the constitution says they
should
and it has not been a constitutional
limit in the past that allows that
however my concern is that the
way that part of the bill is crafted
money is not there for them to handle
those duties
so i too will vote
in favor of that amendment however i
will remind
the public committee members that
because we're removing this amendment
anybody can bring forth a bill
to address this and i hope somebody does
because i certainly would support that
as long as the funding is there
and if you heard another comment that
this section really does belong before
the judiciary committee
so if somebody brings forth a standalone
bill on this it will
get a sure fair hearing judiciary
and for those reasons i'm going to
support the amendment
but reluctantly because of
the constitutional aspect of this
further discussion on the amendment
before the house
committee on election which is to
take out part 5
yes representative prudhomme o'brien yes
sweeney yes representative hayward yes
representative mooney yes representative
yes representative barry yes
representative growing
yes representative quali yes
yes representative ward yes
representative bergeron yes
representative sandler
yes representative hamer yes
representative lane yes
this is racism okay representative
yes representative your head
yes out of chair
yes
um amendment 1390 each
has been adopted as to
sb 89 11 to 8.
madam chair you're incorrectly i thought
everybody voted yes on that
one
yeah 19 to 0. thank you
sorry
you may be getting a little ahead of
yourself madam clark i don't know
very it's very warm in here it really is
glad you're not here they haven't
figured out that about 76
78 okay 19-0 thank you
i believe the count on 13-19
was 19 19
all right the next are there any further
amendments to
part five
the next amendment before the committee
is the non-germane
amendment that was heard this morning
and i'm going to ask representative
mcdonald vice chair
to conduct the vote on
that bill
okay thank you madam chairman do we have
a motion on
this bill amendment number 14
uh yes mr chairman i have a motion uh i
move that
amendment 1445 h of the ought to pass
yes i would mr chairman and members of
the committee
today we heard extensive testimony about
amendment
1445-h and we have received hundreds of
emails
unfortunately this amendment is very
necessary
but it shouldn't be we should not have
to assert our right as a state
to push back against the federalization
of our elections
d.c politicians feel that they can run
our elections better than we can
even though we have some of the loosest
election laws in the country
sb1 or the so-called for the people act
would actually make them even looser
if the dc politicians who crafted this
bill were accurately naming it
they would have called it the for the
politicians act because of the extreme
giveaways
in it such as a taxpayer funding of
political campaigns
today i asked several times where our
federal federal delegation is
why couldn't they be bothered to come
and speak about this amendment
and the for the people act not even one
submitted a written statement or sent a
surrogate to speak
on their behalf we also heard today that
none of them
none of them have spoken to the
secretary of state's office
about how this would affect new
hampshire or why they are supporting it
i find the arguments against this
amendment to be incredibly disingenuous
first they tell us that we will be
costing the state a lot of money and
being forced to hold two elections
let's be clear about something the only
people who are forcing the state to do
anything
is our federal delegation in washington
dc who despite spending the last seven
months telling us how great the new
hampshire election was
now are catering to their out-of-state
donors and trying to undermine new
hampshire's process
next they tell us that they will be that
we will make it more confusing for
voters
but let's be serious for a minute the
only one proposing real changes to how
we
to how we vote are the politicians
peddling s1
telling us how great it will be to turn
over control of our elections
to unelected bureaucrats finally they
tell us
that the federal government has the
right to run our elections
this is the core of our disagreement who
should control our elections
is it new hampshire or dc bureaucrats
for me the answer is clear i pick new
hampshire
every time i will choose secretary
gardner over nancy pelosi and chuck
schumer
every single time i would like to
address
one thing out there that is not true on
april 11th
senator hassan won a wmur and said quote
before the people act it really doesn't
change the way new hampshire would run
its elections
the way it runs its elections already
fits the requirement
but the senator is either lying or
ignorant as to the effects of
s1 that's one character dramatically
changed
madam chairman point of order i i would
say
submit that the gentleman's previous
remarks relative to the senator
are out of order they they are my
remarks
she's it is not true from we've heard
from the secretary of state's office
s1 would dramatically change how new
hampshire conducts our elections
it would require us to allow ballot
harvesting up to 10 days
after the election mr chairman excuse me
mr chairman you did not rule on my point
of order
it's it's noted representative cody
it is does that mean you ruled on it
well representative barry has already
made that comment it's already
it's already out there well yeah but my
but
my point is that his comment relative to
senator harrison is out of order
i'll take that under
s1 would dramatically change how new
hampshire conducts
our elections it would require us to
allow ballot harvesting up to
10 days after the election and it would
ban voter id which is extremely popular
including with support of over 50 of
democrats
the committee members who are about to
vote against this have spent the last
six months telling us new hampshire
elections are well run
so why are they now not standing with us
under the very simple proposition
that new hampshire should continue to
run its own elections
the same ones that we're claiming are so
well run
let's be very clear about the vote we're
about to take we will get to see where
we as committee members stand
do we stand with new hampshire and our
voting institutions or do we side with
dc politicians
this is a battle of choice and the
options are as plain as day
do you stand with a congresswoman from
san francisco and a senator from new
york city
or do you stand with the people of the
granite state and the voters that
elected you to your office
i did mr chairman thank you uh i would
be opposing this amendment it's
it's hard to know where to start with
with the remarks of the previous speaker
so i guess i i i will address simply
uh the reasons i'm going to vote as i am
uh
number one uh which has not been
addressed this morning
except by i believe one speaker i
believe the supremacy clause of the
united states constitution were some
version
of uh hr one two pass
would control that does not mean that
there are not
there is not an ability to uh adjust
hr1 before its final version to take
into account
the problems that new hampshire may have
or that other states may have in fact
that's going on right now and if uh
if the previous speaker wasn't
interested in making cheap political
points
he could be talking to those senators
that he referred to
and discussing his issues so they could
be adjusted
before the end of this process uh i
think
frankly that the entire this entire
ferrago is an embarrassment
and i will be opposing the amendment and
uh
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr chair uh i'm
about whether committee members who
support
this amendment because they think
that some proposed legislation in
the national legislature
represents an unjustified federal
regulation of state elections
would also oppose the 1965 voting rights
act
for the same reason or whether they
support the voting rights act but oppose
this new legislation that might be
possible but i don't see
why the principle would apply to one but
not the other
the the voting rights act of 1965
um uh made it illegal
for the states for as you well know to
uh
to apply literacy tests to qualify
voters poll taxes to qualify
voters it even sent federal officials
into counties in a variety of southern
states to directly register
citizens to vote it was almost like a
reoccupation
of the former confederacy in 1965
and and you know the provisions of
sb1 which i understand reasonable people
could very very much disagree with for
all sorts of reasons
um don't seem to um involve a federal
regulation
uh would seem to be rather tepid
regulation of state elections in
comparison to the 1965
civil rights act so i just wonder would
you support that
the civil rights act but but oppose this
or do they fall together
thank you
as a republican
i can say even though i was not born in
i would probably i would support the
voting rights act as it was
supported by mostly republicans at that
time
and i find it interesting in a testimony
today that we were told over and over
again to discuss our concerns with
before the people act
other than hoping to randomly run into a
supermarket or something
i don't know how uh we can better do
that other than asking them
to come here and discuss their support
for that bill
here with us or to send
some sort of communication to us and
that was not done
what i made instead was i reached out to
my
local election officials the people who
run the elections on the ground and i
simply
texted them and i said how do you feel
about before the people out
they oppose it using some language
some of it was a little spicy i'll just
say this they think that space
okay that one's worth
so um
excuse me we i really can't hear i can
hardly hear
uh representative pruden o'brien and i i
just care
can you hear me better now the
microphone has moved
thank you anyway i'm speaking in favor
of the amendment
and for the reason why i'm in favor of
the amendment and why it's needed
in in order to address that i really
need to speak about
hr1 and s1
i find it deeply troubling that
our federal delegation has been
silent with their response
quite frankly the lack of response is is
deafening
um new hampshire house hasn't had
any conversation with them
has any conversation with them we heard
testimony today that the municipal
association has not heard from them
they're they're already interested as
the secretary of state's office has not
and we heard testimony from them passed
on this
how they very much oppose that
legislation
again h.r 1 and s1
are in direct conflict with the new
hampshire constitution
we got to reaching out i did contact
my uh senators and
my house member and i have not got a
response back
maybe i will but i have not at this
point so i have been proactive as a
citizen
i did that so
in light of the total lack of
responsiveness on our federal delegation
to address some serious concerns with
the legislation
again not all of it's bad but there's
many pieces that are troubling there's
pieces of it again that violate the
constitution
and we heard testimony today that um
new hampshire we did it we did it right
for the most part
i don't think we need the federal
government coming in and dictating the
micromanaging
every little bit and piece of how we run
our election
so for those reasons i will be
supporting the amendment
representative thank you mr chair
the u.s constitution specifically
assigns the responsibility for
establishing election procedures
to state legislatures
this is about this whole bill
s1 is about election procedures the
constitution does not say the federal
legislature has that responsibility
does not say the courts have that
responsibility nor the attorneys general
and our state constitution also speaks
to the to our responsibility as a
legislature
to establish the procedures for
elections and for that reason i will
enthusiastically support this amendment
thank you representative senator did you
ever hand up earlier
any other discussion on this motion
this was not intended on my part and i
will say this because it was raised a
couple of times as a poison pill
to be honest those of you i would hope
you know me have not seen me do such a
thing
excuse me excuse me madam chair could
you speak
into a microphone
i thought we had somebody down here for
my team that cleared this stuff up but
apparently not
um this was not intended as a poison
pill by any means
but um done by me in light of what has
occurred
um you we can talk about contacting our
representatives to make a change in the
bill but the
reality at the federal level this bill
deals with three things
three distinct parts as i said in my
testimony introducing the bill it deals
with
voting it deals with campaign
finance and it deals with ethics and
election security is also part of the
bill part
one of the bill could easily be taken
out of the bill
if parties want if individuals want to
go on about dark money and campaigns
and getting it out which i find it
interesting from our
sitting senator who has recently
commented on it having received
the most money from out of state in any
senate election in history
that's fine i did not purposely comment
on those aspects because i think there
is some history that clearly indicates
things like the loss
um the pain
finance act have already been in place
in regards to federal financing of
elections
and we don't have a lot of estate level
to do with that
this was brought forward because this
bill is making its way
through the house and senate in
washington it made it through the house
without any changes
and the senate in a committee meeting
had a number of amendments proposed to
it
none of which were adopted now i heard
testimony this morning that there might
be
some changes for example to exempt
polling places of less than 3 000
that doesn't really help new hampshire
it may help places like la
la county has 10.3 million people
and i point that out because
the reality is new hampshire conducts
its elections substantially different
than the rest of the country
one of our representatives routinely
says new hampshire is either first or
last in everything well new hampshire is
sort of unique in that we maintain
the new england uh traditions of town
meetings and we have a constitution that
i believe was established five or six
years before the federal constitution
we do not vote by county the majority of
the rest of the country votes by county
which why makes it makes provisions of
s-1
as to making sure there are drop boxes
in rural
areas that are accessible tell me how do
we resolve that provision in colossae
county
um queens new york is 2.2 million
i bring up those two counties because
those are of course counties and states
of nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
who are big proponents of this bill and
i would just say that we do not
do things like other states and to ask
new hampshire to somehow chip away to
continue how we do things in the face of
county and states
with those kind of numbers it's simply
not
realistic this is not intended for grant
standing this is intended to allow our
communities to continue to conduct
elections
in a manner that they have done so i
don't take
opening shots it's not my style
and it's not intended to be before it is
a recognition of the reality of what is
going on
in what unfortunately is becoming a more
partisan
arena if people were truly interested in
the campaign finance piece
and truly interested in the ethics piece
they'd be agreeing that part one
of the bill should simply be deleted so
my bill is intended to make sure that
it's deleted
as to new hampshire and i want to thank
the committee members for
indulgence i usually try to avoid
bringing forward those
amendments but here we are thank you
thank you representative
and representative thank you mr chairman
uh
yes we do do things differently in new
hampshire and yes
the federal legislation as with issues
in any state
should be examined to see if there are
any adjustments that can be made and
we've had testimony that the
adjustments are being looked at at this
point i
i would point out that there's been much
more attention
in the case of the majority party
to um certain democratic
political people holding power at this
moment in washington
then there has been to the legal aspects
of what
this bill seeks to do which is very
simply to violate the supremacy clause
of the united states constitution
you haven't heard anybody talking about
that because
i assume they they know that the choices
are
either violated or have two separate
systems which they have no ability to
determine
how much it will cost how long it will
take
but they would rather once again and i'm
not referring to any individual but
people can make their own judgments
about the
amount of attention that certain
individuals and personalities have taken
up in this hearing
and so once again i will oppose that
amendment thank you mr chairman
thank you representative any other
discussion on this
um
thank you mr chair i would just respond
that the supremacy clause of the u.s
constitution
does not allow the federal legislature
to violate the u.s constitution
and that's what we'll be doing in this
case
i have a question for representative
groene if you'll yield to the question
well
[Music]
senator cody uh yes mr chairman
yes uh representative oh thank you
uh did uh do you believe that the uh
congress united states violated
the supremacy clause when it passed the
voting rights act of 1965
the voting rights act was a civil rights
act that dealt with
excluding people from voting this is a
process that is telling states how to
run their
elections and i realized that there are
some crossovers between the two
but i think there is a distinctly
different aspect to those two bills
i guess that's what we'll find out but
we find that out in a court of law we
don't find that out here
thank you sir okay
i just quickly want to thank
representative perfect for bringing this
amendment forward
um i i joined the others of our
committee um i do hope we do
hear something from our federal
delegation uh
before they vote uh the two members that
have yet to vote on s1 or h.r one
before they do i hope they listen uh to
the
discussion we've had today as a
committee they read the articles that
are
going to be written about it and can
send us some
form of information as to their support
of this or what changes they want to
seek
and i would urge them to listen to the
people of new hampshire we had
hundreds of emails of people we didn't
sign up on the sign-in sheet that i
think we also need to consider when
voting for this amendment
that are in support of this amendment
that do want to make sure new hampshire
is writing new hampshire's election laws
and i hope our federal delegation is
listening
and takes that under advisement and i
would urge all the committee members
uh to vote for this amendment so thank
you thank you representative
any other discussion
h
representative mcdonald yes
representative
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes tarosian yes
representative barry yes representative
rowan
yes representative quailey yes clerk
says yes
representative cody no
representative ward oh representative
bergeron no representative sandler
no representative hamer
representative hamer i don't see her oh
yeah she is
representative yes i i lost my internet
connection for a minute
um i'm voting no thank you
representative lane no
no representative freitas
representative no
representative
represent your head no i'm sorry
no i'm out of chair yes it
should be 11 to 8 this time
[Music]
are there any other amendments for sb
uh yes madam chairman um i knew that
sp 89 we ought to pass as amended
amendments 1323h 1505
h 1398 and 1445
h is there a second i second that most
dramatic chair
representative second city it's their
discussion
on the motion
i'm not seeing any disgusted in its
parts as the amendments came
forward not seeing any further
discussion i'm going to ask the church
the motion on the floor is sb 89
otps amendment
representative mcdonald yes
representative
o'brien yes representative sweeney yes
representative hayward yes
representative mooney
yes representation yes representative
berry
yes representative growing yes
representative quailey
yes clerk is yes representative cody
no
representative ward oh
representative bergeron no
representative sandler
no representative hamer
no representative lane no
representative hamlet no represent
your head no i'm out of chair
yes 11 to 8. sb 89
has passed 11 to 8.
i want to thank committee members for
sitting through with this this morning
without a lunch break
um this concludes this committee's
business for this first year of the
session in regards to bills that have
come out of the house or senate there
will be one
uh remaining piece of business to do
which is uh
to discuss uh committee excuse me bills
that are being amended by the senate
that we have passed there are a few at
this point that i expect
so with that if there is any further
business that anybody wants to bring
before the committee
i'm not seeing any thank you everybody
for participating this morning
enjoy the rest of what we're going to be
one of our more and nicer days
thank you